you know what i mean it's hilarious there was one more game
we like solo exhibition that we had to play and he just
wasn't there oh my god okay that's pretty funny oh i like
you yeah that's pretty funny we were in the spot to win the
whole tournament the entire tournament but we got crypto
altered altar pushed into a building and died like in three
seconds it was the weirdest we died in literally like two
milliseconds crypto alt alter kill boom and then he just
left he just like he even went offline on discord no he
didn't even say bye I just saw him disappear on Fuggy I just
saw his eye disappear okay that's pretty funny that's pretty
funny oh sorry god that's why he's my idol he's the money
yeah he's toxic like you yeah yeah he's my hero i feel why
can't you be more like zero like i invented toxicity in apex
to be honest sure like back in my day when i was competing
back in my day okay grandpa it's been two years okay grandpa
that's like what 20 years in internet internet dude one
month is one year is it two years is zero win two years ago
it's been two years since i competed yeah was a zero also
like better than what you should say nothing but that
doesn't matter i i invented toxicity in apex legends you
meant toxicity in apex legends yeah i remember the day it
happened when we got contested by six russian teams in
overlook yeah what did you do that was a dark day what did
you what did you say we won every single contest and t-bag
the fuck out of them get being toxic until they left oh do
we have to put the delay on for our team no no no what the
fuck we're not even if he says we have to i'm not doing it
yeah we're not nerds i don't do anything we don't need to
put tsm in front of our names they know who we are they know
we're tsm team team slightly manhara only slightly only
slightly yeah yeah yeah we are locked and ready we're so
locked in guys fucking are ready up right are just start no
shit my boy yeah yeah doc is here we can go yeah i'm here
already just i don't know i should see that
just starting who cares about team five oh my god oh he's
starting oh my god he's starting let's go no we're not
exactly they don't need that guy all right here we go I mean
why should we wait for one person at the beginning three
minutes late this man was late when I got in there was like
20 like not 20 there was like 15 people not even there yet
you can't say that doesn't get to speak you also told him to
start you said the same thing i was first in the lobby you
said the same thing you told him to start about this man yes
yeah but but i get to speak because i joined on time and i
just repeated what you said no i repeated we're not fighting
guys we're just having a discussion wait wait wait
For your uh, Dita, for your upgrade, just pick the wall
upgrade two times.
I forgot.
Which one?
Left side or right side?
It's, I think it's right side than left side, but I'm not
sure.
Just read it.
Okay, I really need it.
Dokey, your upgrade is, I think, I think your upgrades are,
fucker, I think it's something with duration of scan.
Oh, yeah, I remember.
Right one, the right one.
for me what are you i'm left all right did it your job
master no no no no no no no no no no no no i don't know
where i'm going i'm waiting i'm waiting my flag in case
macnama all right guys guys listen yes yes imperial rpr
we're gonna scan every single beacon until we have purple
armor this is the strata okay what about like what about the
armor thing and we're opening every single red bin for
turbocharger oh we have every single one we have scan yeah
that's why we're landing here we're gonna scan people and
then we're gonna scan me though i'm gonna land the far right
okay we're gonna scan people and we're gonna skin zone and
we're gonna just fucking get purple armors no more blue
armor i believe in us you sound so enthusiastic yay wait
what placement did you end up wait we got tents wait wait a
minute there were people here uh murder them in cold blood
like wait what the fuck somebody what who landed next to me
i wasn't even paying attention oh they're over here they
landed there okay i'm fine these are objects oh i i have a
lot of ping today
80 pink this is 84 pink to me this is east this is a new
server this was supposed to be dallas is this dallas i'm 84.
kudos kudos said dallas but i think he's lying to me and we
think this is like organizer trying to sabotage me wow i
mean it's not dallas i think it's it's just um not america
dallas is na listen scan the beacons oh man okay oh why do
this why do you do this we had both scans too we had both
scans as well this is sabotage this is actually sabotage
scans scans are 100 spawn by the way oh okay this is not
sabotage dude he's just being an
What was it?
I did.
I think it's unfair because I have three hours.
Hurry up.
I have it in bed later.
Havoc and fucking flatline and they restart.
I think this is like targeted by the way.
Please.
Do they use the same server when we scream?
I don't know.
Oh.
hey i'll just play like video game wait what placement did
you guys end up getting for the jp tournament 10 uh we were
like fifth last game but we were like if we won the game we
would basically win oh that's why zero alt for yeah and then
we got honestly we got hit by the most toxic push i've ever
seen in my life by which team which team yeah which team did
that jp jp JP team.
Call them out.
Controllers, of course.
Call them out right now.
They crypto-ultered us, and then they alter-cued behind us
into the building, and then Maggie bold us so we will
double-stunt.
I couldn't even take out my Havoc, I already died.
It was insane.
What the heck?
What haste that come?
Wait, wait.
What placement did they get, though?
Probably worse than us, Dominic.
What if they're higher?
What if they're actually higher?
I don't know, but we were...
we were owning solos we got second second and third in solos
all of us were going crazy in solos yeah but then you ended
up getting it doesn't matter how crazy you were you you were
still 10th place we don't have we don't have any we don't
have any team you said 100 spawn rate you fucking liar yeah
i lied so what what you said it was a hundred percent spawn
rate quick somebody crash right now okay you out the four
right now wait why do i have to alt f4 i don't even have i
don't even have f4 on my keyboard i use a wooden out f and
four then oh my god oh my god it's okay like it's your idea
you do it like what do you want from me you clearly want to
do it you clearly like the idea so you should do it because
you're captain no i'm not no i'm gonna embarrass my name
with your ideas my idea it's our idea how are you no no
you're not doing this we added this idea together as a team
you're not doing this today this is not long this uh well we
gotta figure out where we're hitting beacons now by the way
i'm i'm reporting kuro on fucking on lgs like never let kuro
organize it he's getting fucking reported he fucked over our
first game never again yeah he's reported yeah bad for life
yeah buddy count your days buddy you're done you're done oh
go back back never mind i don't have my guns anymore can you
open can you open this supply mouse yeah i will but we need
to figure out what the are we scanning i guess geyser you're
okay i will go i will go take um okay what about harvester
uh evo yeah yeah take that i'll go take that i have a white
backpack i feel very poor the chi or geyser okay the chi or
geyser long side scanned us okay long side better not scan
us because they're gonna get these hands what if they kill
us okay are you whose team are you on I'm just talking at
the possibilities You're like not bringing any confidence To
the team at all I said what if what are the plans If you
know I look at a contingency plan Like what's the plan if we
die That's not I didn't say we die What if they scan us?
I said what if they scan us?
What if they kill us?
No I said scan I said scan Somebody is not paying attention
Why is she lying now?
I think you are You just need to fix your ears Why is she
lying?
My VPN to North America, only North America.
Oh yeah, you did.
For me.
Yeah, you should.
Let's go Geyser.
Who the heck told me Dallas?
Yeah.
RPR.
I think he's trying to sabotage this.
Oh, wait, wait.
Enemy here.
I'm with RPR.
What the fuck are they doing there?
Let's go Geyser.
Okay.
I fell down.
What did he say?
Dallas?
Like, he's trying to sabotage this.
Guys, how do I get back up?
Where are you?
Hurry up.
We gotta go do shit.
I'm not even further away from you.
Ditto's further than me.
Yeah, but she's closer to the gold than you.
Come on.
Where is?
I don't even remember the gold.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah, they're close.
Kill this guy.
Kill, kill, kill.
Solo, kick.
One guy's solo kick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe they might push me.
Yeah, and this wall.
No, no, you're good.
You're good.
I'm with you.
We're here.
15 15 hp left blue armor right here okay on this hill he has
charge rifle i win no i had one wait but i don't see him
correct 40 flash 40 flash i don't even have an angle i think
they came from geyser so that means guzon is probably on us
right could be oh yeah that maybe i don't even see it yeah
everyone's here and here yeah everyone is coming to our side
okay oh so we have the zone yeah we don't get to scan for
for purple armor man where should we go then rpr just here
and we have no other option now yeah but like where do we
where do we play oh my god i will play these two houses all
right have him this is our home now coast coast equals on oh
they're fighting here flash flash i'm going in okay okay
okay okay we're coming over we're coming over are we pushing
i don't know let's let's break the doors and and try to poke
because these guys are flush what if they take our house
wait wait there's a guy here yeah here behind the pillar
he's right careful i don't i don't have my shield cell and
battery i have i have 16 cells okay goodbye i guess
everybody should leave i don't know get the top of our
building oh wait there's a rampart that's a rampart floor of
this building right here all right heading over that's a
yeah that is a rampart okay let's actually go back to to our
original house okay yeah oh i see this oh maybe i need to
kill this oh there's a bad spot for me i might die what the
oh no i'm good i'm good i'm gonna good i'm feeling sick okay
okay we're eventually have to kill that team because we won
that spot to be honest.
Maybe we kill them now.
Dito, I want to give you some cells.
I can scan the six.
Yeah, yeah.
Here, I'll give you cells here.
You want me to scan now or wait?
Yeah, scan as soon as you can.
I'm going to get a right side angle.
All right.
Oh, they left.
Oh, they went to the left building.
Okay.
I'm going to take this building now and I'm going to break
their doors and then we just want to bully them if we can't.
If we have nades, we want to just throw them.
Yeah, I have nades.
too okay i'm on the high ground the door that is not quite
it yeah i broke the left door are we trying to they're over
here yeah just play the scan oh i got i got they scanned me
they know i'm they know i'm alone here yeah there's a lot of
team oh yeah i need help i need help i need help for this
i'm trying to cover you i knock one i knock one at the here
here here here i knock We need to focus on behind.
We need to focus on behind.
Yeah, crack the other.
We can't let this team get close.
I will run out of...
Heavy ammo.
I'm gonna look in front of us.
I'm looking in front of us.
Just in case.
I'm getting bloodhounds in behind.
I think they get laid.
Yeah.
Yeah, they rest.
That's fine.
They're running all the way back there, back to the car.
Okay, so focus on this team again.
I'm gonna see there's heavy...
I'm gonna find heavy ammo.
120 and bloodhounds.
I need heavy ammo.
yeah i'm looking for ammo right now we're going out to get
ammo from them guys we don't have another okay okay okay i
will draw my knee yeah yeah throw a need they are blue
armors this is good for us to get purples they have lifeline
though they have lifeline though which is okay almost almost
kill bengal or we're gonna fully commit i can now yeah i'm
ready wait wait a night he's pushing I'm smoking in there so
smoke when you can I'm looking behind Oh yeah, they're
getting red pushed They're getting red pushed Revenant
cracked One of them got knocked inside Flash, flash Are we
going?
Yeah, look to third party this We got a Okay, I'm scanning,
I'm scanning Holy shit No knocks, no knocks No knocks
There's no locks No, no Yeah, they rest They have lifeline
rest So just stay close Stay close here And wait for them to
fight Oh yeah Okay, I'm waiting We need this We need the
skills Cause we need ammo Oh, there's so much light though
i'm gonna look behind us there is a there's a team that
redeployed behind us yeah right behind us i'm trying to get
them off our backs uh we might yeah we need to kill those
guys fucking hell maybe i have to change my phone yeah oh
this team is speaking this team is speaking at the wall here
okay okay who the fuck are you guys it is i got a phoenix
it's no there's nobody in the house yeah there's nobody in
the house yeah i scanned it okay okay we got the what houses
did.
Well, we didn't get any fucking ammo, though.
But there's people on the bridge now.
There's people on the bridge.
Okay.
These guys run here.
Okay, I got this house now.
Watch behind us, because that team behind us is, like, the
biggest problem for us.
I might just swap... I'm going to swap my gun and go both
short range, because I see so much Arnan here.
I'm going to give you my heavy.
Okay.
I just see, like, all light ammo.
these guys are getting railed here but they got a package
lifeline package okay oh nobody's behind looking okay people
cross the bridge we were going this way in this way
everyone's going that way and they're all fighting there i
kind of want to like do something to them still 20 spots
that's the thing yeah i have only one about three cells i
have two about six cells i have one bat five uh
If they fight on the right side there, like I kind of even
want to look at them on the bridge They're gonna try and
come over here.
We get keep that.
Okay.
Okay Yeah, they're dropped below bridge and they're getting
beamed Walking down there they're going up.
Can you hear me on my ping almost k?
They're heavily split Oh, she's alone.
I'm getting shot.
I'm gonna shot my back from the building one guy so alone
i'm gonna shot from behind we might have to go back to the
building okay i have no heavy ammo yeah so far whoa i
haven't had more ammo i'm so i was like i seeing you i
smoked this i don't know is he on the left side yeah he is
he's on the left side purple armor okay we're still they
have to come to us oh you're right yeah these guys have to
come to us we're good we're good so we have to chill our
issues we have nomads or ammo so we have to win a fight yeah
we can't peek anymore where you want me to scan okay i want
p which direction is getting the team in the big building or
like on the bridge bridge direction would be good um share
me some this share what do what i have this much heavy no i
already gave you all my heavy i have p bullets wait i think
we should go to the house over and use catalyst on the wall
like use like make catalyst doors okay wait wait wait he's
looking so annoying yeah this door as well we're just
relaxing please don't hurt us yeah yeah that's good that's
good this door and that door i'm gonna scan should i scan at
the big house i yeah it keeps getting I fucking hate that we
got zoned because we have no loot.
It pisses me off always We're just little guys I hate
getting zoned I changed my gun.
I changed my gun.
Oh, you changed it?
Are you?
No, you don't.
Oh, no, no, I don't have I have fucking 24 bullets in my
hemlock.
Oh, but I have a lot of a lot of energy.
There's a redeployment behind us There's a there's a
redeployment behind us by the way Look at it Cracked.
First guy crack.
Okay.
Flesh.
He's dead.
Nice knock.
They're right in front of us.
Be careful.
He's thirsting.
I'm beaming them.
Are we gonna get...
I just want to finish the kill.
Did you finish it?
Oh, they did.
No, they didn't.
They lifeline res.
Right here.
Oh, okay.
I can't get.
I don't see them.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, they're gonna fight.
Careful, you shot from the dragon shot from behind, careful.
Yeah, I'm good.
Be careful, be careful.
Be careful, I'll work back too.
Yeah.
I can scan.
Look at this blood on.
One, one, one on the blood on.
You should have blood on.
Flash.
Stop shooting me the back, asshole!
Focus!
We're literally helping you.
It's my last bat.
You have to fucking kill these guys.
Yeah, play on Ditto.
Play on Ditto.
Okay.
Scan these guys and let's see if we can kill them.
All right.
They scanned us.
I have one cell, no bats, but this is insane.
Oh, this is a full team.
I have one, like one cell.
I have two cells left.
Two cells left.
Oh, nice.
There's a team on the house, by the way.
I kid you not.
We have to fall in this team.
All right.
I can bloodhound all the guys.
Look at this in below.
Okay.
We want to fight each other.
a fucking i'm gonna i can i can scan everyone i can scan
them in one i can scan them in one scan scan scan scan yes
get that get that let's get to my right nice i'm dropping
down i'm dropping down and i'm gonna try and loot some okay
okay you guys stay up okay okay okay okay okay i'll see is
there do you have loot do you have loot rpr i need energy
and light i'm trying to get as much and meds i'm trying to
get as much as i can they're scanning me though i can scan
in one Keep looking in front of me.
I'm looking.
Be careful.
Yeah, but I need some comments.
I fly over there.
I'm trying to help you.
I can make you a wall.
If you want.
No, no, I'm good for now.
I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna try and loot this box.
Be careful.
I want to make a wall and go to you.
I don't think you can.
No, no, no.
I need, I need.
I have a redeploy.
Do you want to take my redeploy to climb back up?
I have one.
I'll use it.
I just need you guys to watch this dumbasses that are trying
to fucking kill me.
You're fine.
Two seconds of the smoke and then I'm smoking.
Guys, I'm over on the right side.
Oh my God.
We can't.
We might have to drop.
There's a team looking at us.
Play up top if you can.
Play up top.
I can.
Okay, then come to me.
Then come to me.
Okay.
Is there meds in there?
We're gonna have to full kill this team.
I'm gonna make a war and I would swap my armor because I
don't have anything.
Okay.
I have I have one battle in like 11 cells come with me here.
You gotta play here No choice cells here.
I need get as many nades as you can and wait.
We can go back up now.
We can go back up.
Yeah We go back up in the corner the other side is not even
going anymore They're not underneath that.
Oh, wait, wait.
What the fuck?
I didn't get that scan Fuck balcony can see us.
It's fine.
I smoke No, it's not okay.
They can apparently just see I was gonna we're all here just
chill i don't think that guy team can push yeah no i'm fine
just block us block block block yeah the the bangle is oh
wait it's okay it's okay yeah how can he how can he just do
that just play behind my knockdown i can't not yet not yet
you don't see me yet he's just staring at me can you crack
him once and then rush me and try okay
bloodhounds can then maybe oh my god i can't pick you up
yeah i used this shield res already just in case you can
armor swap i already armor swap i already armor swap i
already used it i'm gonna heal it in my own smoke we gotta
go over in a sec we gotta go over as soon as i pop this yeah
i'm taking your stuff okay i'm getting over because this
corner is a dead sentence getting behind this rampart wall
to pop i have no more bats and i'm 11 cells i don't have any
shields for you I can give you shields.
I only have syringes.
Okay, I'm going to have to...
I'm going to have to bangle this.
Okay.
We're going to have to play left side here.
I see a team right in front of us.
Right here.
Yeah.
I'm going to bangle left.
There's a guy here.
I think solo.
Solo, solo, solo, solo.
We're getting poked at, though.
This is my old.
We can play in this.
Play on me.
Yeah.
And we slowly move.
I knocked someone in front And I cracked like crazy Kill the
guy He's alone Nice, nice I knocked two people here in the
smoke Okay, I'm gonna go here Play the head glitch Play the
head glitch It's one guy No, it's not It's full kill, it's
full kill Yeah It was the one guy Oh my god What do we get?
I knocked two people there And these guys your team they
full killed them i got the kills yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's nothing we can do their zone came on us yeah we were
so poor i hate getting i actually just hate getting his own
it's so fucking so bad that i hate it so much there was
nothing we can do i mean you got kills and sixth place or it
was a fifth place we had to because if we don't kill people
we don't have loot if we didn't get if it didn't kill people
would i should be poor and the guys we killed were also poor
so it's not like we got anything everybody was broke guys i
mean we made it pretty far with how broke we were yeah i had
one bat too we did pretty good with how far with how broke
we were we killed all three of them and got like four sales
I didn't want to And that guy that saw us through smoke too
That shit was fucked up Honestly, I'm not gonna lie I
fucking won't clip that guy through smoke right there In the
end Wait, but you called him out Yeah, I'm not gonna lie I
used candy I smoked him and just won't clip And my old Noct
one hound is so rich he actually has meds that's not fair we
got sabotaged by the game leader there was just so much we
had to control with so much little resources that's messed
up i bet you that first game would have been our winning
game if we didn't get sabotaged yeah we had two beacons we
had red band we had everything yeah we had everything i had
my my gun load out i had all like everything i ever wanted
in life
look at this meta dude smoke skin i mean they're rich they
actually have loot it's not fair yeah i mean we just have to
like when we're broke we just have to win fight and take out
yeah there's no other choice and this is also this lifeline
team is the team that we knocked when they landed below like
this was literally the team but they got second place we
knocked bloodhound and then they used lifeline rest so we
didn't get the kill for it and i wanted to finish i couldn't
because guaranteeing grief it's okay we killed the other
team that tried to get in sorry we did the best we could
with the yeah with the situation we had we had we got kids
and we got sixth place let's go tsm could never do that the
old tsm that's why we're the new tsm yeah old tsm sucks yeah
old tsm fucking sucks they could never do something like
this yeah yeah i mean old tsm got 17s place
that's all i'm saying we did good considering the fact that
we don't have famous just and we have that's true that's so
true so real for that we're so real for that you're so real
oh my god you're so real for that oh my god you're so real
say your truth say it to the world all right I did so I can
get some coffee I'm fucked right now Storm point or is it
still World's Edge?
I think it's World's Edge.
It's three World's Edge and then three Storm points.
I'll be back.
I'm going to grab some coffee.
Okay.
I had drank my first coffee in like six months for this
tournament.
It's crazy.
First coffee in six months?
Yes.
Wow.
All right, I'm back.
Are we still doing the same comp?
With the refrigerator, it's like right outside my room.
Oh, you're getting ice coffee?
Is that what you're getting?
Yeah, I'm getting ice coffee, canned coffee.
You know, fake coffee where it's just sugar.
Is that like, I used to drink just like canned coffees from
Starbucks.
Like actual Starbucks canned coffee is like iced coffee.
No, it's like Japanese canned coffee.
So it's mostly just sugar with some caffeine in it.
But Japanese canned coffee, you have two options.
you have the the sugary one or the black coffee oh no the
sugary one i'm having the sugary black one i cannot i don't
know how people that is crazy like how do people swallow
that wait dyrus is in this lobby wait since when wait since
when though i didn't see him i think lincester stirred
didn't join so he got dyrus to play oh my god we have to
kill dyrus we have yeah I mean We can make it happen We have
to kill Darius Darius gonna be like What the fuck dude Yeah
Sure I think we can be good friends
Ditto Do you know who Darius is No He's a ex-professional
league of legends player for tsm oh that i wait i think i
have ever seen him yeah dyer is yeah he was pretty famous in
league of legends yeah and now he's he's he's like what's
the word he's wild on twitter now he's wild and free yeah he
gets bullied by vtubers tournaments now in apex yeah how the
mighty have fallen he he loves me okay i i wish i wish
someone would not um disconnect i sense uh sarcasm in your
voice ducky yeah my voice always has sarcasm but it doesn't
mean i am sarcastic that's double sarcasm right now you're
stacking it like a If I get double sarcasm, it counts.
That's like two negatives.
It cancels each other out.
Do you not know simple math?
That's not how it works in sarcasm mathematics.
It's literally cancelled each other.
What do you mean?
What are you some fucking PhD professor?
Yeah, I literally invented sarcasm mathematics.
I literally have PhD.
From where?
And PTSD.
Oh, hey, there's a triple take.
there's so much so many triple takes i'll take a triple i
shoot too much ammo like i need to become shiv i gotta carry
like stacks on stacks apparently i shoot way too much well
to be fair we had like literally no resources oh i forgot
the game audio sorry guys can you scan the people beacon
right now Yeah, yeah.
Not even there, though.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Can you do it?
When you get there, can you scan the people begin?
Alright.
These things right next to me, so I'm gonna get this.
I kind of want to open the red bin behind us, but I don't
want to go back, so we're not doing that.
You're so lazy.
What happened?
No, because we have to rotate.
What happened to you?
When did you get so lazy?
It's not about laziness, it's about efficiency.
why are you so lazy our efficiency is not allowing us to go
back we got to go forward look at his own yeah but i have to
scan anyway yeah hit the scan and start walking towards me
i'm like no heavy again this game doesn't spawn heavy ammo
all right scanning in three two one do you need heavy mag no
heavy ammo i'm okay i'm ready oh there's people here okay we
can go for this and this on the way all right and that
should have a lot of heavy ammo i have a redeploy a lot of
you i need heavy and energy too i have a lot of energy i
give you like i can give you 160 energy all right i'm just
gonna check these bins real quick oh i i can't give it you i
have like run straight toward me guys okay i got heavy i'm
heading over Yeah, we gotta kind of move fast.
We gotta fast rotate.
There's 20 teams now.
Ditto!
Ditto, you're so behind!
I'm dropping 80 energy here.
Okay.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Another 80 energy here.
Maybe even more, actually.
Oh, nice.
I'm heading over.
We're so fast.
There's no bat.
Oh, fuck.
I got bats.
Purple bag.
This shit.
There's a havoc here.
Purple bag.
Oh, I need Davok.
I need Volt.
I'll take that.
I'll give you Volt.
Okay, I reach.
Okay, okay.
Here, I take this Savok.
You take the Volt.
I have two short range, by the way, because I couldn't find
a long range gun.
JK, I found a long range gun.
But I might...
I need scope for it, though.
Okay, we'll maybe find some in fragment.
We want to hit the juicer here and then we want to hit
another people scan.
okay and then after that we want to probably go for zone
yeah and this zone is this i think it's this annoying one
north side which one this one on my ping this one okay i go
north of epi uh there's there's a bat here can you carry
yeah yeah i'm gonna carry the heavy if you found a skull
energy i have both of you need scope okay people are here on
top of i have two x so i'm okay now okay there's people
right here i just saw rotate they're gonna rotate up the
hill here okay i would read a play yeah we have two read a
place there's guys on top of the building are just gonna
keep the skin leave someone's beaming me my back keep we
gotta keep moving forward oh i see them they're really right
behind us yeah yeah get to the diner come keep walking with
me they were here 30 seconds ago okay yeah that's the team
in front of us brother come with me we're gonna go i have
scat and nine hopefully this team hopefully this team is not
holding this hybrid i need you to scan here all right five
four three two one we nobody okay we're good they have
caustic barrel be careful okay okay they scanned the survey
beacon we can play from here okay we're not last let's go
people died before us I love it when people are more
incompetent okay are they fighting on the right side yeah
because if they are we can maybe do something about it okay
I want to keep moving forward I want to get as far north as
we can because I'm fuck you oh that's embarrassing no I'm
not bloodhound I can't see that I didn't see that either
okay i heard a sentinel from this side let's keep moving
okay all right we're right behind you here i've scanned 18
because i used it earlier they're at the sentinel is at the
house so we should be able to get here for free honestly we
could even play for third beacon and then would probably
give us purple armor we want me in this building scan this
i'm scanning people in there here.
There is no other choice for us to play from down here.
I don't think we can get any more deeper.
What if they, like, shoot us from the top?
They're not because I'm gonna hold it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
They also, they have to, they have to hold their house.
Motherfucker, get off the fucking triple take.
Where are they?
Yeah?
On the roof.
Yeah, on the roof.
I don't see them on the roof.
If that team is too, oh, wait, I see a team going left side
inside the climber.
Look at them.
What's them?
It's two teams, I think.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
Oh, wait, I missed every shot.
I haven't done it yet.
Guys, I have not played the 30-30 in too long.
Get fucked.
Oh, no.
I haven't shot a 30-30 in a long time.
Be careful with the soft team.
Is there any team on toss?
Yeah, no, there's team in this house right here.
Doki, I want you to keep scanning in this direction behind
us in case anyone's trying to walk out.
to us we just need to know if there's people trying to
contest us okay i can give a two-time scope i have a two x i
have a two x i just i'm just not hitting shots you want two
to four uh oh maybe yeah two to four is better for me here i
just wanted oh here someone's uh evaking and this i'm gonna
watch it fucking emote where the fuck oh they're coming
straight for us i think they're flying over us red armors
already what the fuck they're gonna fight 100 no they're not
i mean they're definitely lining up people red they might be
they might just guy from walking around and scanning yeah no
these guys are just ripping scans of cooldown honestly we're
like one scan of uh purple as well so We just didn't get a
chance to scan anything.
But where's Endzone?
I guess we could have an overlook.
Whoa.
Endzone is somewhere around us.
I'm not sure exactly.
It's either pulling to climatize or coming back to us.
Yeah, did they play from below?
Wait, they're fighting in the bottom here.
Like full fighting?
I don't know.
I saw like poking down there, but...
And they were running at the building.
I keep looking at that.
Oh god, there's too many places to look at.
Focus, focus on looking below and scanning behind us.
That's all you got to do.
There's a team on top of Overlook Tower.
They're fighting over there.
They threw a fuse name.
Why did they get shot?
Can this triple take fuck off?
Oh, that's your chase.
I'm not here.
I just got hit around the corner.
Yeah.
I smoked him.
He just picks the door always.
Really annoying.
Leave us alone!
Don't fucking destroy your fence.
You kind of have to save meds so the same shit doesn't
happen from last game.
Yeah, they're getting shot too.
Maybe you can pick up a killer.
I think they're fighting here.
Okay.
Yeah, I think they're full fighting.
Yeah, yeah, they're full fighting here.
Come here, Doki.
Look at this.
Okay.
I will hit a shot.
I swear to God.
Do you want to swap?
Do you want me to give me a repeater and I'll give you a
hemlock?
No, I will hit a shot.
I swear.
In this corner, look, look, look.
Guys.
Look at this, look at this.
These guys are...
Oh, he's dead.
One dead.
Guys, maybe I'm just...
Maybe I'm just bad.
There's so many teams here.
I don't know what to look at.
up here okay we have to get keep these guys and all of this
entire side because we have this good side over here okay
let's do that i'm waiting i'm gonna just keep smoking this
house oh there's a guy behind this rock there's like three
teams here three teams here but it goes can by somewhere
i'll probably really far can you scan in this direction it's
not it's not flying what's the I scanned it.
I didn't see anybody.
Okay, okay, okay.
It has to be far because I didn't get... Oh my god, I hit a
shot.
I hit two shots, guys.
But these guys are...
These guys have to die.
No.
He's in zone.
He's losing zone.
What the fuck is he living?
I cracked him.
He has to blow.
Yeah, he's...
Oh, he's dead.
Nice.
They're rising.
They're trying to res.
One more.
Nice one.
They should be able to res, though.
I don't think so.
They're getting shot from every side.
I don't think they can.
I didn't get my kill.
They crawled inside, I think.
No, no, no, no.
They're resing.
They are resing.
I see them resing.
You stop shooting him.
I'm fucking ulting them.
I don't know.
Fuck.
They got the res.
Yeah, yeah, I saw the res going off.
What the heck?
How can they?
How is no one beaming these guys?
He just stopped.
That's actually crazy.
one to give us kill maybe oh yeah they're still here yeah
yeah they're inside my purple can't believe it oh they're
rotating they're rotating out they're rotating out they're
rotating in these guys are gonna die i think nobody's
shooting yeah look at the blood on look at the blood on last
guy last guy right here yeah i'm reloading i could yeah he's
going he has to die 20.
behind us oh he got shot from behind i'm dropping i'm
dropping ditto i'm dropping here that's so unlucky we're too
busy looking in front yeah i can't believe that they too
rotated so easily if you can come to me ditto it's kind of
okay where can i ride here oh my gosh Sayonara Sayonara Can
I go to you?
I want to go above us somehow Do you have it?
I have ball What?
Have ball?
Come here and evac here so we can go above here Okay, all
the time Come to me and just put evac we have to go up here
So come here Oh my god, Ditto is so far No, no, she's fine.
She just has to cross the lava You got this Ditto They can't
hear you death okay yeah and we jump up here on the rock
okay okay and we play here oh i like how ditto is the one
that still got shot you actually how are you shooting me
you're literally smoke i have no heavy top five for me oh
man i had all the heavy ammo in the world If only the
bloodhound didn't die.
Dito, just crouch here.
We can't make sound.
If the team above us peaks, we die.
It's rat time.
We have to rat here until someone drops on us and then we
kill them.
Okay.
I think there is a team here in this corner.
Yeah, there is.
Look at them.
They're going to fight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They will.
Okay.
We don't kill this guy.
Don't shoot.
No, no.
We grip him.
Okay.
That's it.
I grifted them and I have a crack too.
Okay.
They're full body.
Oh, we got scanned.
We got scanned by on top.
I didn't get scanned.
Only you.
So they'll think she's a solo.
Because they fucking hate you.
I don't know.
I was with you.
They just hate you.
Isabla?
Maybe isabla?
I mean, you just say you're getting scanned and then it
didn't pick up.
I was a little bit in front of you.
That's why.
Okay, they finished this fight.
I believe in top five Maybe top four We're going to be a
little wild Now I got scanned But it's really It's max range
scan So there's They're scanning from like here It's max
range Okay okay Okay they're right above us It's not Okay
yeah yeah I think we're really good here If we just We're
going to walk here Yeah yeah Okay they're right above us
They're looking over Careful Don't let them see Yeah, they
saw me.
They saw me.
Oh, they altered.
Fuck him.
But they have Bloodhound.
Wouldn't even be able to see that?
Oh, they're rotating.
I think they're dying.
Those guys rotated.
Tito, we're going to play like here.
Okay.
They're right above us.
That is just...
Look at this guy's fighting.
Oh, guy beaming me from the left.
said oh god this is annoying everybody wants to kill you do
you not have another redeploy is it up here no no redeploy
now i'm lagging all of a sudden no oh
my gosh this is intense sit where i'm how many chill cells
you have left ditto um chi okay one live is okay i have i
can Nice.
I'm gonna bang old here.
I can't even ping it.
It's okay.
They shoot another team.
This team is gonna get beam from right side.
Like, look at this team.
Look at this team.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
What the fuck?
How can you see me, dude?
Just doesn't like you.
all right we're dangling here i'm full healing and we're
gonna play right side slow okay made
oh i'm so unlucky i
can't even hit like he's teleporting
i didn't see that oh she's actually teleporting there's
insane wait they're teleporting that fucking sucks yeah for
me that's so unlucky yeah everyone's teleporting this is
insane is it still storming or no i don't know what's going
on we're back all right hey we got top five no that was
dyrus's team yeah we go top five wait i think you knocked
dyrus oh wait he did he knocked dyrus You know what?
That's great.
That's all I care about.
And we got top five.
Oh, we got zero- we had zero kills for top five?
We didn't kill anybody?
I'm surprised that we didn't kill anybody.
Yeah.
I guess we just- we knocked like a lot of people.
Yeah, so we didn't- we didn't get any kill.
Yeah.
Oh no, our PR is pulling a zero.
He's gonna alt have four.
What the fuck was that Bangalore banner?
That's Lynxer.
And he's been doing Pro League.
Not a full VTuber tournament, guys.
Because I think there's not enough VTuber Apex players in
NA.
Back.
Welcome back.
Did I get any kills for that?
No, we didn't got zero.
I would win that last fight if I'm not lagging.
Oh yeah, yeah, I could tell the first mag was not very
inspirational.
I should have used my oil.
On my screen that first mag was all over him.
Literally aimed straight at him.
Yeah, yeah, on my POV it was not inspirational in my POV.
It was literally a fullness.
He was teleporting so where I was shooting he wasn't there.
uh this shit again i'm tilted what did you fix it or i don't
know what did you do i literally don't know you do anything
to fix it or no i turn off everything in my house like from
the wi-fi oh i'm gonna switch my vpn as well maybe that
helps tell tell tell the organizer to do one game in europe
i mean half the team is eu anyways so I have to turn it more
than I should know one third of people in this tournament
are EU anyway so might as well I mean I'm fine with it as
long as I'm not lagging like when people start teleporting I
can't play the game like I mean I can't hit people like how
am I supposed to hit people when I can't see where they are
they're not like where I'm shooting they're not there change
the server change the server I don't know if switching to EU
would help
man that's unlucky because it always happens like in the
second or third game for you because it'll be okay and then
suddenly bam it was fine in the morning i played an entire
tournament today in the morning was completely fine oh my
gosh sabotage maybe he is dedossing you
maybe we are getting sabotaged all right yay game will
restart what do you mean game will what do you mean please
announce new contest game will restart oh shit wait you're
not even in the fucking lobby wait a minute yeah i have to
restart my game
what does he mean by game will restart i don't know i hope
he's not restarting a whole game he's gonna keep us here at
4 a.m or what no they cannot i told him i was like i'm
leaving three like you literally can i literally cannot i
was like if i'm doing this tournament i have to leave at
exactly three oh so ipn is grieving that's what's going on
wait how so because apparently you aren't you're you need to
announce a contest and they contested without announcing it
oh oh wait who did he grief I don't know.
Whoever lands Overlook, I think.
Oh, so they're not going to count that game?
No, they're counting it.
But he said moving onwards.
If that happens again, he's not going to count it.
Oh, that sucks for that team in Overlook.
That sucks for them.
They got fucking griefed.
They should, like, deduct points for that team.
They should...
IPM, yeah.
IPM should get minus 40.
Yeah, yeah.
They should deduct points.
no i've actually got minus 40 points so you can't win at all
like no matter how many points you cannot get past top 10
because you grieved you ruined the game for everybody else
who's ipm playing with uh fruit and zero a fruit and zero oh
my god fruit zero and ip are grieving that's insane they're
griefers i know that's what i'm saying they should minus the
duck points wow there should be no mercy pros and griefing i
know no no two pros and griefing is crazy i know you gotta
do the honorable thing and have one pro and grief hey but
we're not grieving griefing our own team maybe okay well
that's for you
Ditto carrying us.
Let's fucking get beacons.
Okay.
Ditto.
Carry.
Carry with everyone.
Yeah.
Ditto, what happened?
You used to kill everybody.
What happened?
Don't gaslight her.
She's doing her best.
I follow RPRs already.
You're supposed to give her confidence.
I'm so RPRs making you a worse player.
How am I?
I literally have the most kills in here.
here and i'm not yelling i don't know she said um she said
she's literally following you and she's not getting kills
that's what she said see she agreed i'm gonna lose my mind
i'm useless again how many ping do you have in a you you
should have blaze being more than me well the problem is not
the ping i have 150 ping and it jumps on 200 then i have 150
and jumps on 200 and it makes everyone teleport it's your
internet like it can't be my internet i literally called my
company twice to full restart everything and they did maybe
how do you know it seems not lagging how do you know they
did it everything because everything went down for like half
an hour maybe they just turned it off but they didn't i
don't know but it's oh i got my landing so i'm gonna steal
your loot i don't know what's going on oh i'm gonna steal
people's loot
yeah I don't know how to fix it even like oh thank god I got
a hemlock this time I have no idea
again maybe it's just apex but it happened to me in Valorant
the other day as well but I don't think it's fixed I was I
was playing yeah but I was before I fixed it on Valorant I
was playing on like an NA server with like 200 so it's kind
of could have been this shit oh 3x are people still
teleporting for you or is it fixed now no it's not fixed
it's never gonna be fixed no no how much challenger oh can
you guys skin okay actual gameplay sabotage so oh actually
i'll take that i forgot i'm running hemlock uh i'm dropping
a 3x if anybody wants it i want it i want any scope do you
want 2x i have an extra 2x gx gx i'll take anything all
right
i'm heading over we have zone we have zone again yes we have
a zone again no it's like we should play like from this side
where you guys are So stay there.
I'm going to get some evo charge here.
Yeah, like on this building or this height.
But I think building is probably easier.
Okay, I'm going to craft it.
Okay.
Okay, I got 3x.
Oh, yeah, 3x?
Okay.
I'll keep my 2x here.
How are we going to get that 3x?
I need sculpture.
Uh...
Nice.
I have three bats and eight cells.
Three eight.
I have two twelve.
I didn't really find a lot of bats at all.
And I can't find a havoc.
I can...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Who's getting the...
Are you getting the Harvester or are we getting it?
Yeah, I mean, if you can, get it.
But don't die for it.
I already got one of them.
I'll get the other then.
Wait.
Shouldn't...
like you should be getting this not me i'm way too far away
okay you're oh sorry you are oh somebody was here somebody
was here probably tree team got the harvester
right i got it okay nice i mean we our only option is really
just playing zone we don't really have much one option here
we're just gonna live here it's okay we're not gonna be last
I'm pretty sure it ends on this bridge, like right there.
Should we go to that bridge or stay here?
No, no, no.
I want to play from, like, this corner here.
Those walls are really good.
I will check.
Yeah, that's why I want to play from this building and the
walls.
I hate holding these walls because, like, you just get
knitted.
I like pushing it more than holding it.
I don't see anybody yet.
I'm gonna put four soldiers.
Oh.
Over there.
I see them.
Yeah, they see us too.
What the fuck?
Oh, he came from...
These guys came from Geyser.
Geyser?
Or was it?
They came from...
Not Geyser, big mod.
These guys came from big mod because he has the paintball
gun.
Okay.
Did you hit the...
Oh no.
We didn't have people's skin, did we?
No, we didn't.
yeah
I'm checking if anybody read a place to us Dita you play
there and play safe throw your cues everywhere we're gonna
play roof and just look around and try to get information
when it gets like when a lot of people start getting here
we're just gonna play here Dita's gonna play there and then
if it gets like dicey we just run to her and play from like
Dita's side like we want to we don't play those walls over
there okay and we if we can keep this high ground we we
won't do but if we can't we'll just give it up and play
walls instead because these walls are pretty much gonna win
as the game okay
nobody's rotated to us yet yeah over here okay they're very
far oh very slow they're just playing edge i guess yeah i'm
like because like usually zone teams would be here already
so i'm like I don't see anybody yet.
I don't even see any redeployers.
Oh!
The team jump over here.
How close?
Where the fuck?
Where I'm pinged.
Oh, okay.
Purple armor.
These guys are playing super slow.
What the fuck?
They're just taking like a million bacon skins and shit.
Look to my left.
Why is this one so low?
That guy's flashed by the way, this guy.
Yeah.
This is blowdown.
Look at this blowdown now.
Is it him?
He's going to move.
Yeah, he's going to move.
Stop shooting.
I'm looking to your left.
Oh, there's a team coming rotating in behind us.
Blue armor.
Okay.
I'm just going to make sure these guys...
Whoa.
Okay, they have triple takes to get off the roof.
Yeah.
This is not going to be a fun game for me.
Yep, they are coming to us.
I'm gonna scan.
They're just chilling.
Oh, okay.
It's pretty far over there.
Yeah, yeah, we're still pretty far.
We're still pretty good.
What the?
Oh, bridge, bridge people.
Okay, bridge is fine.
They can hold that.
That bridge team is like, I'm like 99% sure they're gonna
die because everyone's gonna focus there.
Okay.
I'm still checking there's extra resources.
Okay, one team out, the tree.
Bridge team is no longer at bridge from what I can see.
Okay.
Yeah, they went below.
There's someone getting charged-rippled like crazy at three.
Over there, over there, over there.
Over there, here, here.
Yeah, in this truck.
So, Dito, you gotta watch that zipline because these guys
can be here.
I'm looking behind us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If someone gets close to you, just run straight for me.
I can smoke for you.
Okay.
We'll just give up that house if we have to.
But for now, just pretend like you're a full team there.
All right.
I'm a full team.
Don't come near me.
Yeah, they can hear this, but that works.
Oh, come near me.
I'm standing on the roof because I'm so confident with my
team.
One team that are in a tunnel.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I shouldn't stand on the roof anymore.
I'm going to shoot it.
I'm shooting tunnels so they know I'm here.
I'm getting a long boat from fucking...
Oh, this guy's dropped down.
Okay, they dropped down.
One guy dropped down.
Two of them, I think.
I think all of them dropped down.
Yeah, they're going for this build.
They're gonna hold that building.
I cannot see people behind me anymore.
Oh no, they're over here.
Okay.
I need to save my heavy.
I just run through heavy.
There's people over where I pinged, northeast, 72.
Okay.
Three.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm just poking them.
Just being annoying.
Just let everyone know we're here.
That's basically what we're doing right now.
much noise so people are afraid of like pushing this area
and if we get evac we just have to full fight for the spot
we can't lose this spot so if i get like pushed here i need
you guys to instantly like come here help me here we do not
want to give away these walls because they will be our one
condition i'm so scared of rotating up here on the roof just
watch like in that direction just no one's walking up from
you Oh my god, I got shot by four people.
Oh my god.
Okay, Dita, I'm gonna go for a banner.
I got shot by so many people.
Okay, I'm gonna go away.
I got shot by two different teams.
I hated here.
Really?
Guys, never...
Okay, that's what happened to me.
That's what happened to me.
I told you!
I don't know, stop.
Res, res, res, res.
I told you!
Once you behind us, punch me behind us, yeah.
Yeah, they're pushing, they're pushing, they're pushing.
From where?
You get my ra- Oh, okay, I'm holding that.
Okay.
She didn't get the rest, she didn't get the rest.
Yeah, I can smoke for you later, just stay alive.
What the fuck?
Every team is looking at us.
I will go on time and cover you.
Yeah.
Where do I land?
I'll go, Bob.
A Bob probably is the best.
You cover.
Everybody's running sniper.
Yeah, it's just normal.
I can smoke your box later so you can take your shit.
If we lose this spot, we didn't, right?
I don't see anyone here.
Oh, here I am.
I don't even know if I can.
I'll smoke your box later.
Okay.
I think I got these walls.
Yeah, I got them.
Oh, there's landing.
They're landing on the house.
One team landing.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
We can get up.
Fuck this.
I'm going to run sniper next.
Yeah, I see him.
This blue armor.
This guy's alone, I think.
One is me.
No.
I can't, like, I can't hit her because she's teleporting!
I'm gonna scan behind us.
Fuck, that's a loot box of juice.
That loot box is juice.
I want it.
Cover me?
Uh, okay.
Okay, okay.
I'll stay up here.
I'll stay up here, guys.
I'm just a little baby.
I need ammo, ammo, heavy ammo.
There's no heavy ammo.
There's only light ammo.
Okay.
I have seven bats.
I can give bats.
Okay, yeah, I don't have ammo.
Can I have ammo, dad?
I don't think you can, Dito.
You might die.
Maybe if I give you some.
Doki, Doki, three bats right here.
Yeah, I'll take it.
You need cells?
Here's four cells as well.
Yeah.
Wait, is someone zipping behind us?
They are.
They're above.
They literally came up when I dropped down.
That's fucked up.
You have to play for me.
Oh, my God.
That's fucked up.
I literally got over here.
These guys are going to get bullied by everyone, so it's
fine.
How is he seeing purple armor?
Okay.
I'm so sad.
I literally got off just for the...
It's literally like that...
We got a hyper-focus that team.
For that loot box over there?
Is there attachments in that box or no?
Yeah, like 301 attachments.
Oh, 301?
I can smoke it if you want.
Oh, no, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
Wait, is there a scope in there or no?
Probably.
Yeah, two times.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need it.
Can you smoke it?
All right.
Okay.
Okay, we got to only watch this team behind us.
This team literally has to push us or they die or they have
to go below.
So this team is like hyper priority right now.
They're getting crypto-ulted.
Okay, I got him.
Okay.
These guys get crypto-ulted.
What the fuck?
Why?
Wait, I'm not here.
I think it's just to get griefed I don't know I'm running
purple armor I'm gonna run low on heavy again I can give you
my heavy and I'm gonna swap to a carbide if you want that I
should wait no there's no light ammo in there never mind
there was 200 can you smoke can you smoke the replicator 20
seconds 20 seconds you gotta keep looking this team behind
us guys okay I'm looking I'm looking I'm looking in the back
like Oh bro, you guys are so fucking annoying.
Okay, I should have poked it.
I can scan the replicator, but I don't know if you want to
go or what.
All right, you're gonna smoke it, smoke it, smoke it.
I smoke it if you want to build ammo.
Do you want to do it?
Keep looking at this.
What is that smoke?
What the fuck am I watching?
Okay, I'm going to see if I can swap to Carbine then with
Ditto.
Yeah, just make sure you craft ammo and then come back past.
Both of you craft ammo.
There's a team in front of us.
i'm back here i'm back i'm beaming them i'm beaming them i
cracked one i cracked one you're fine you're fine okay keep
watching this team behind us i'm gonna i'm gonna smoke and
i'm gonna when they push i'm i'm ulting now standing i'm
standing behind us just watch them just literally watch them
what about the team behind us that team behind us yes just
watch them the team above okay i'm looking i'm watching i'm
watching this is the only me out to watch oh i keep beaming
them there's a team in bridge shooting at us they're getting
pushed by zone now look look look look look okay i'm looking
i'm looking i'm looking i'm looking purple armors they are
too they're being with us i'm gonna i'm gonna bloodhound it
all i see them scan them when you can i see inside here is
free scan scan scan okay i dodged i got hit by that really
okay i got hit i almost beamed on team on the left team on
the left looking at us Just focus on this team only.
Focus on this team only in front of us.
They're still here.
I cracked them.
I got a bat.
This is not their crypto.
This is not their old.
Yeah, I'm batting.
I'm batting too.
I scan.
Just focus team in front.
Focus this team in front.
I'm not focusing.
I'm focusing.
They're all cracked, bro.
Yeah.
Flash, flash, flash.
Oh, fuck!
My game!
All dead, all dead.
But another team behind us, maybe.
My game all tab!
What?
One dead.
I got green, my game all tab for some reason!
Did it play on me, did it though?
There's still more in front.
I'm so sad.
I got the heal, I got the heal.
I got the heal!
I told you.
Yeah, but it's... don't worry, it's near fault.
Yeah, my game actually all tab.
This is a few laggy bullshit, man.
holy shit i'm shooting at a guy there's nothing happening to
him can you tell him to swap maybe swap servers i don't
think it's a server thing i'm not sure just sit live just
play like play your life two guys in front of you did though
yeah just play your life did oh just rat just rat yeah just
play below you can they're probably gonna fight each other
you'll be free if there was a team true below us in the
earlier so careful
you can go close to the truck later i think left side all
the way left side if you walk with zone you should be okay
left side yeah like there i don't know how i i don't know
why it's suddenly tabbed out it was crazy maybe click the
alt to them or maybe no my game like suddenly tabbed out of
nowhere yeah that cliff maybe tito is that in right in front
of you
Oh, hey.
What about left side?
Right here.
Not in.
Yeah, she's not in.
She's also in zone now.
Play behind the truck.
Right there.
Oh, right side.
Person right side.
Nice.
Good kill.
Someone's in truck.
Just play behind the truck.
Just crouch behind the truck.
Seal their door.
It's okay.
She's fine.
When you seal their door though.
yeah oh no no you forgot to lock it you forgot to lock it
what i lock it no you you open no they opened the door when
you sealed it so you have to close it again before i stay i
stay i stay only one guy yeah no way that's one guy we got
top five we're always top five i'm fighting a bloodhound and
i'm shooting havoc at him and there's no numbers coming out
of my there's nothing it's like because you're streaming
maybe at this time when you're streaming in no because it
was happening off stream as well so i don't think that's a
stream thing we're consistent guys it's the pink because i i
didn't i didn't see the um door open yeah my stream is not
dropping any frames it's not lagging like it's perfectly
fine my discord is just a game if the game is just fucking
like i don't know maybe it's maybe it's apex i don't know
oh my god a person or maybe it's your vpn um it's it's
pretty much the same with everything it's just more pink you
shoot north america not that light yeah it's not i'm i am on
north america oh how was the first game first game was fine
first game then how How about you change to Dahlia's again?
I can, yeah.
That's so weird.
I wonder why you're having these problems.
I don't know.
It might be my shitty eyes.
Does it only happen during, like, our tournament thing, or
was it?
Because it was okay.
No, it was happening during my, like, when I was playing
Ranked, during stream, it was happening, too.
It is kind of my one, I think.
Ha!
Look at him looking funny hopping to shoot back.
just shoot back i don't why is he just moving maybe they
didn't have reloaded oh is that 1v1 this could be a 1v1 yeah
yeah i think this is a 1v1 if they're not if he's not
getting pushed wait they're not why are they so scared oh
why are you yeah why was he so scared okay let me try
switching maybe again okay
have ended it early guys yay top five again we're consistent
we keep getting top five with no kills because i can't kill
anyone we got four kills oh did we okay yeah we got four
kills that's something but i i could have killed both of
those guys there if he wasn't just teleporting shooting a
whole hell clip and nothing comes out dude it's so stupid
also I think he needs to like change the he needs to keep
changing the code because I think the server gets laggier
over time let him know that I don't think he has more codes
I think he only has one wait this is a custom code no I'm
pretty sure this is literally just a random server code it's
a custom code oh from apex oh yeah it starts with a p uh
random server code start with a c but why would he why does
it matter does it matter if you get if you get a code from
ea it's higher quality because dedicated server oh i see and
uh i'm guessing he only got one code because yeah 15 minute
15 minute what am I going to do for 15 minutes oh yeah
there's a 15 because they're going to interview the top 5
teams so we got chill why would you do it mid turn me and do
it after you turn me yeah yeah wait why can't you just do it
you're right though this should be the end of the turn why
are we mid turn me interviewing like what They got to pad
the tournament.
I think.
They better.
Okay.
I guess like they're not...
Did you see me?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, yeah.
Yeah.
They should.
They should be.
Why would they interview me?
So I can tell them their server sucks?
Do it.
We're not top five.
We're not top five, though.
We're top six.
Good.
Thank God, no interview.
That's my plan.
Midway, the first three games, top six.
They're going to interview it.
And then you win the last three games.
Oh, haven't we won a game?
We don't far.
Are you seriously asking that?
I mean, like, whatever.
RPR, why haven't we won?
I thought we're TSM.
I don't know, Doki.
It's kind of hard to win two or three, you know, like when
someone, when our team dies on a roof, our team dies on a,
on a wall, he's like, wait, who died on the wall?
Fucking?
Who died on the wall?
Jesus Christ died reincarnated on the wall.
What do you think died on the wall?
I know it wasn't me.
You had selective memory?
Okay, stop the cat.
Selective memory, looking ass.
I contributed I think I were exactly six so no interview
yeah we don't have to talk to people but then you have to
talk to me fuck yeah which is better right yeah so much
better it's like so much better I think we should change our
comp no why we didn't get first I don't think you get a
input on comp But like we didn't get first though Both of
you have lost your ability To put input anything about the
comp Just gonna put that out there Both of you have lost
that ability I no longer listen to you I am the captain Okay
I found the main steam I'm gonna watch main steam The main
steam Wait we're gonna check out the interviews yeah i'm
surprised you're interviewing five different teams that's
like a lot of teams why why should it be like three because
like who cares who cares when somebody is like top five like
rank four and five they should just interview you though
killing honestly true they should just interview me i'm the
most important i mean yours three needs to know what you
said before You know what she said?
You know what she said before she started streaming?
She was like, RPR, you shouldn't stream so I can get all the
viewers.
And I was like, you already have enough viewers.
And she was like, I want your viewers too.
He's twisting the story because he literally was like, I
don't want to stream.
That's what he said to us.
He's like, I don't want to stream.
And I was like, oh, I should.
Okay, then don't stream.
Just don't stream.
That's good.
So then I get to keep all the viewers.
No, you said, you said, I don't want to stream.
You literally said, I don't want to stream.
stop gaslighting i said should i record this conversation no
no actually actually i will say exactly what i said i said
do we have to stream and then you said you don't have to do
what we have to stream comma like quote unquote i don't want
to stream no no no that's not quote unquote i don't know
it's not i said do we have to stream and you said okay if i
was like do we have have to stream if i said it with that
it's just a question if i say with that intonation everyone
will know that i don't want to stream you said it with that
that's not how it works you guys later let me finish my
sentence i said do we have to stream doki said you don't
have to if you don't want to i said i'm going to stream now
no no no but you don't have to and then i was like why but
like i'm going to stream and she's like i want all the
viewers i said you have enough viewers
Okay, quote for quote.
Ditto, who's right?
Am I right or RPR right?
Ditto, come on, Ditto.
Ditto, who's right?
Come on, Ditto, don't betray me.
Do you want to hear my answer?
Yeah.
You're going to betray me again.
It's okay.
I'm asking.
It's okay because everything was recorded on Ditto's stream.
So, like, whatever you say, everyone is going to know that
you guys are lying.
Because there's proof.
No, everybody would know I'm fucking right.
I've never lied in my fucking life.
That's true.
That's the first lie.
I'm the most honest man in this universe.
That's already the first lie.
You're not the most honest man in the universe?
When did I lie?
You're more honest than fucking Jesus?
Yes.
I'm the reincarnation of Jesus Christ in Apex Legends.
Reincarnation of Jesus Christ who lives in...
Eastern Europe.
I've never lied my life.
I would never fucking lie.
That's so fucking cap.
Ask me anti, I won't lie.
How much do you earn per month?
I, NDA, NDA can't tell you.
Literally NDA.
That's not a lie.
That is literally not a lie because I'm NDA.
I literally can't tell you.
It's not a lie.
Who the fuck did you sign a contract with yourself?
It's literally your own earnings overall.
fucking esports org what do you mean you guys said overall
that includes everything not just your esport earnings if
you include which also includes my salary which i can't talk
about no i can't talk about that or okay how much do you
earn paramount how much do you i asked a question first i
never said i never since it's since it's that easy to answer
that nba question i'm a liar i'm a liar i can lie anyway but
we all know you're a liar you're just proving my point yeah
but I'm trying to prove my point that you said you never
lied.
Then fucking tell the truth.
How much do you earn every month?
I told you through NDA.
I'm not going to lose my job because of you.
I don't care that much.
Just minus your esport earnings.
Without your esport earnings, how much do you earn?
For my esports earnings?
I mean, what are I earning?
Like 150k or something?
Without your esport earnings for a month?
Without my esports earnings?
Yeah.
I don't fucking know.
Like around 2k-ish.
I don't know.
2k ish without esports and then 150k is overall that's my
we're talking about esports earnings my esports earnings
i've earned 150k my career no i meant like with i meant your
esport org i'm not can't tell you that i can't tell you that
minus minus your esport org what's your current salary per
month earnings i told you i literally told you okay told you
around uh around 2k without yeah because it depends on the
month oh okay so on twitch you earn 2k a month and other
shit wait what's other shit like sponsors what are you
asking me like you know what kind i don't know when you get
a sponsor well now we know look see chat now we know his
twitch earnings and sponsors great wow like you could have
calculated your yourself how could i you said nda yeah you
can see my sub count but you can't see my salary that's in
the age so you can calculate the twitch side your own
there's literally no sub count on your stream i have your
stream open it's under my stream where oh there it is
there's a sub goal guys i saw it it's public info
guys it is public info he was right you know he does doesn't
he doesn't lie okay ditto what question you want to ask rpr
what creation why do you only want to know about money like
you could and you focused about money like you could have
asked me anything in the world to be honest about what do i
ask you i don't know what do you want to ask i am in here
i'll say about i'm a 25% men here and as this conversation
keeps going, it's the number is increasing.
I mean, it's obvious he's a men here right now.
Like 100% men here right now.
No, I'm 25.
But if you keep talking, it's going to go up.
Do you like Stokke?
What?
She's okay.
Do you like Stokke?
Yeah.
Am I a good person?
yeah you're okay no i i asked you if you like turkey am i a
good person not not not she's okay yeah i said yeah she's
okay yeah yeah she's gonna get an ego dude like she's gonna
get an ego from it like no i'm not i know i know i'm not no
because i already know i already know i'm amazing
person i know is he's a manhara i'm like literally not
somebody like he is he is he always talks about how like how
he hates being here but yeah every time i ask him to do a
tournament he says yes yeah yeah because i bring in the
content i gotta bring in the content for you like who's
gonna bring okay yeah i'm literally a content machine
content machine machine yeah what about ditto yeah he yeah
um when when we play um dta together and when i asked him
for money he always um sent me money even if he told me that
um he didn't want to give me money wait really can i have
some money yes i don't send their money she's literally
lying i have some money yeah i should ditto you make like
probably 10 times more than me like what walls do you want
from me?
Like, you give me money.
How about you give me some subs right now?
Why are you asking us for money?
Why are you begging for us?
Cause I need it.
I literally need money.
You're like pulling.
You make 2K a month.
Don't talk about my salary.
2K is like an estimate.
Like some months it's lower.
Sometimes it's high.
You know how Twitch works.
But you also have your esports salary that you won't tell
us.
So it's more.
An esports salary that may I ask.
that i'm still not receiving because i haven't moved to
japan by the way yeah that was that's that's your own issue
now that's a visa issue that's you you can move at any you
can live technically you can sort of start living there
how would they know i think i think for all the content i i
i create here you should give me some subs for real and you
should give us subs for giving you content you should give
us subs for giving you content because we're asking the hard
questions here like can we end this intermission i already
had enough of you guys can we get some primes in the chat
for this bullshit yeah so you go to uh search my name up on
twitch uh dokeybird at twitch and you can start a hype
you're so How am I greedy?
You literally greedy.
Like, you're literally greedy.
Like, you're the greediest person I know.
How am I greedy?
Well, do you see what you just did?
What did I do?
I just said, can I get some primes in my chat?
Yeah.
Go to DocuBird Twitch and start a hype thing there instead.
Like, what is your problem?
I just said instead.
I said if you want to.
Let other people eat too.
holy shit let us eat too if you want to it's your choice let
me eat too
whoa rp are you why are you so mad relax bro if you're mad
you you can't yeah is your for the knee smash if you're you
have to calm down or you might you might like lose your hair
you're gonna start malting you're gonna start molding i have
the most fullest head of hair on the planet like i literally
will never lose hair sure i'm like like i have so much hair
i could donate that's that's the level i'm at i mean i'm
gonna go to her get a haircut on monday so my donate
everything gets off me yeah wait i'm going for really short
how many subs for you to shave your entire head i'm not
gonna shave my head i did want money he doesn't want money
guys listen uh i am an honorable man that draws a line and
will not sell my soul he doesn't want money to get myself
embarrassed on the internet okay oh so what being bald is
embarrassing for me yeah for me it is he doesn't like bald
people guys he hates no i think some i think some people
look amazing bald i'm just not that guy You don't know that.
I don't look good bald.
You don't know that.
All I'm saying is.
You never been bald.
Right?
I have been bald before.
How do you know?
You don't know me my entire life.
I've been bald before.
You said you've never, you said you have a full head of hair
and you'll never lose it.
Oh, thank you, Baka, for the tier one sub.
I'm no longer cutting it all off.
You're insane.
This is insane.
Like, this is not even a conversation.
This is not even a conversation.
Shit!
Bomba in chat!
50 gifted!
Holy fuck!
Hype train!
Bomba!
Dude, I think he is like 100% manair.
Oh my gosh.
I'm here.
I think he's going crazy.
Sorry, I got nuclear bombed in chat.
It was crazy.
Holy shit.
Oh, hey, I have Hype train.
Nuclear bomba.
Oh, I'm almost close to Hype train too, guys.
holy we got bombad oh my god how do we live this how do we
survive there's a nuclear bomb i literally have listen doki
i've had about like a hundred chatters today from your chat
come here and apologize in your stead they're like sorry
that my or she's the way she is in my chat i have i never
lie in my chat i have people coming in my chat being like oh
my god he's lost it he's crazy and they're they're
absolutely right they're absolutely right i've lost the plot
a long time ago i never lie you're like i would never
apologize for doki and up here's up here chat um always come
to my team and say um up here's fault it's okay that's up
here fault yeah this is just like a blast to me that was
created years Hey, 15-minute intermission's done!
Our intermission's over.
The 15-minute torture is done.
Same comp?
Yeah.
Same comp.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They should call that shit 15-minute torture, bro.
Oh, God, thank you for the hype train, everybody.
Thank you for the five gifted subs to the Doki Bird Twitch.
Really appreciate it.
Guys, wait, RPR, what's your highest hype train?
Oh, shit.
How do I know that and like maybe level 16 or something
during my subathon oh it was during your subathon oh that
makes sense yeah i don't like honestly like my community
like like we we don't have oilers and i'm fine with it like
i'm not really money i'm not a money hungry person in
general like as long as i have enough to survive every month
i'm chilling i don't really care about being like a
millionaire or being rich as fuck i just want to have fun
and live like be alive buy food yeah pay rent as long as i
can pay your money for my gosh yeah okay wait wait a minute
that's less honorable as long as i can give this big
corporation all my money that i earn with hard work every
every month
be okay as long as as long as i can give them all my money
then yeah i'll be good you know what she's right you can't
judge her rpr you spend money on apex i'm judging i don't
tell you i stopped playing money on apex like a year ago but
you had you did though but okay hear me out i was
money of the game that's why i don't judge you by buying
skins i was single-handedly increasing my price pool every
tournament you understand so i was investing into my future
by buying skins think about that think about that for a
second no that's stupid i did i thought about it that's
stupid whatever why would why would you why would you invest
in the in the game when you could have when you can have
other people invest in it.
Because at a certain time in my life, I was actually naive
and believed that this game was going in a good direction.
And then I regret all of my choices.
I'm only playing it because you invited me to this
tournament.
Yeah, but you were playing it yesterday.
Yeah, because I was practicing for the tournament.
Yeah, but then you were playing before it.
But you played before I invited you to the tournament.
Because I had Apex Matsuri.
And I knew that I had to practice.
so much why do you keep saying yes to apex stuff because the
only good thing is like playing tournaments in this game
like this is the only fun thing in this game is you're
having fun with us no but you listen that's the only good
thing wait why don't you exit stop gaslighting me scan the
zone okay oh i have mvc i scan the zone scan zone i scan the
zone wait i want to crash though i need you only one i need
two your one
wee oh he is so sunday i know guys yeah he is sunday i know
he straight up was like it's not true you should have said
you only enjoy playing apex and tournaments but then you're
like not this one there's no exceptions because i'm lagging
there's no except yeah but you were lagging in the last
tournament too no i wasn't i wasn't like in apex mastery now
you're just lying i'm not talking about this last one i'm
talking about the other last one which i wasn't also lagging
in there's a team in front of us okay i was again laying i
forgot yeah yep why are they here can we kill them yeah
that's what i'm saying who the fuck do you think they are
okay they're in my are they disappeared they're in my
fucking swamp i don't see them anymore though are they
hiding in the they're in the bowl they're in the bowl when
did they get there oh my god 20 wait we killed these guys i
think they have charge rifle i have the charge rifle i'm
trying to find another sniper i can't find one oh there's a
longbow okay never mind i got it because i was like i'm
tired of all these other snipers i want to snipe too wait
the zone is not here or they're going left they're going
left okay i think i we killed them here they're going to our
spiders oh i hit him real hard with the fucking aid look at
this guy i'm terrible i'm terrible i'm actually terrible i'm
coming over i need to be closer i'm terrible don't talk to
me i don't want to talk to you oh that's i stopped to i
stopped to right behind okay okay i'm looking horizon look
flash flash flash flash flash flash i'm trying to flash i'm
trying to yeah i'm just they're all dead oh my god boba tea
lovers oh no we did this to them is that team is that guy
dead too on the left side yeah they're all dead okay he's
here i see them they're on the right that's a spider oh is
that a spider those are spiders don't you have a sniper like
hello he was peeking behind the rock that's nice okay sniper
stop here oh i need that yeah are we locating no where do we
go i mean i i'm killing these spiders for evo okay okay do
spiders have moves bro i can't hit them that's just sad dude
they're tapestry what do you mean sad that's just sad
imagine losing to a spider well i didn't take any damage so
i'm not losing technically imagine losing to in front of
your entire chat guys i would never miss a spider i'll miss
a person guys i'm getting bullied again like can we get i
miss a person guys but Can we do something about this?
Like, we're going to be bullied again.
It's just not fair.
About what?
About you.
I'm just having a conversation.
Just like how the other TSM have conversations.
I'm not allowed to have a conversation with my team now.
It's only working hard.
Dido, was I bullying?
No.
Yes.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh my god, there's three bad.
that's here yes I already have what is the wrong with me
okay I'm coming over here with me wait wait wait are we
getting shot yeah yeah back behind us behind us behind us
behind us behind just come to me we're chilling bro why are
they always fucking using triple take why why wait the the
zone is not here why they're here yeah they're fucking
stream sniping for what okay i'm gonna need that i need that
loot everybody's using triple t that's so weird i'm gonna
grab that purple helmet though yeah get all that juice and
then let's get smoving oh hey wait they did have fucking uh
they had everything yeah they had they're so juiced what the
fuck someone's flying over you guys oh they are let's get
smoving I want to rip this and I want to rip this So that
should give us purple Oh, I'm getting shot at Why the fuck
are they shooting, hello?
They're mean They're so mean I think they might be, they're
chasing They are?
I didn't even get a chance to grab the bats Maybe they're
chasing Yeah, I'm about to come over to you I cracked one
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here Whoa, I'm not here
yet Bro, fuck all How do we get Chessie?
I only have...
These guys might jump in too.
Oh, I'll give you...
I'm dropping four.
Okay.
I don't have a man.
Now let's get moving.
Like, I don't want to get stuck in some stupid longbow
dumbass fight like across the planet.
Everybody's using sniper now.
Okay, let's hit this people beacon.
Okay.
Juice.
And then let's hit the ring console and then...
we should have purple right i'm like very close to purple
you're really yeah i'm like 50 of purple oh oh no oh no
where was my body block not okay guys i think we're fucked
bloodhounds low we're getting tripped in our back i think i
think you guys should go just leave just leave why me i
cracked one why me guys i don't guys i don't want to play
bloodhounds anymore okay wait where was my smoke rpr i
didn't think we needed it i gotta take this goodbye okay
they didn't finish you so we can maybe resume yeah i'm gonna
hide behind i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying i'm gonna hide
team are they evoking towards me please i will murder all
three of you come come right now i'll handle all three of
you guys i can take three guys are they still They're
evacuing away.
We can rest.
Can you rest?
Yeah, yes.
I'm here.
Then push.
Hello.
Hello, everybody.
Guys, I don't like Bloodhound anymore.
Just heal up.
Guys, I don't want to play Blood.
I fucked up.
I fucked up the heels.
I thought I had time to met you.
I'm going to heal you with the smoke.
I thought I had time with the met you!
all right i tied it incorrectly we're going to scan the zone
after you've done that okay after you i don't have i don't
have much um i have one match kit as well okay and then i'm
gonna i have a real player too why there was your party here
and they didn't here we go again here we go all right
somebody what the am i looking at right now because i only
have one med kit we gotta get the out of here get out of
dodge okay i'm gonna cough okay i need a syringe okay i got
i'm gonna cough here do i have time i think i might die
while i'm redeploying i'm actually dead because i have no
syringes i have a med kit but i don't know if i have time to
pop it yeah i'm dead i need to
Ditto, do you have strange Ditto?
I need one strange.
Yes.
Are you rising?
Okay, you're rising.
Okay, I'm gonna back run then.
I need one stranger.
I can heal.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Okay, I might be dead again.
Okay.
What the fuck?
They're camping!
They're camping, they're camping, they're camping, they're
camping.
Okay, okay.
Fultim, they're pushing up, they're pushing up, they're
pushing up right now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
I think I've already.
It's a full team.
Do you have Evac, Dito?
I had Evac, though.
They were like crouching outside, too.
We have 20 seconds.
We just have to go straight.
We have another choice.
Oh my god.
I got fucking grieved so hard.
I had no meds left, I think.
I don't know.
I don't want to die.
I have to read the play.
You have to get... There's a callus spike them from you so
yeah this is what it is we are not sure what to run through
it you guys have a mobile respawn though yeah but these guys
are gonna be our biggest problem yes we have a wall we have
a wall perfect oh my god i almost saw my old so one time did
you guys get my redeploy uh i don't know i didn't get i have
mobile mobile come with me i get my ult i'm gonna side okay
okay two percent one percent oh there's a guy up the rock
there's a guy off the rock i just saw him this guy from the
left is annoying this is my old i'm probably dead yeah
you're dead what is wrong with people why are you guys
playing like this guys we shouldn't play edge we didn't have
we weren't edging there we were going zone but Everyone else
was, for some reason, rotating towards us out of zone.
Because they don't have to rotate.
So they rotate into us.
How does that make sense?
Did everyone swap?
I don't want to play Blood Out anyway.
I'm getting bullied on Blood Out.
They don't know where they're going, so they're just running
randomly, I guess.
What the fuck is going on?
I mean...
Maybe we can play like casual, like, um, kill everyone that
we see.
Yeah, maybe we have to just murder people.
I think so.
I think we just fight.
We should fight.
We can fight.
We can't fight.
Because we can't rotate because we will, we will do stupid
shit.
So we just have to fight everyone.
Fight the horse over.
Might as well.
I mean, we have to get kill points now at this point.
Yes.
Yeah, we're just getting like, I mean, I got fucking, I got
capped out.
I literally saw a guy fucking hugging the wall.
like three teams came to us like outside the zone i i don't
know why two teams came to barometer behind us barometer was
nowhere near the zone like and then sandwiched us with two
more teams that were in prowler nest so we got sandwiched by
four teams that were not in the zone and not moving towards
this isn't a jp tournament this is a this is an naeu
tournament yeah i forgot brain cells here nobody rotates you
gotta remember nobody rotate just fight everyone just get
good look fight everyone get red armors fight fuck it
there's too many control players in this in this lobby for
there to be any iq involved so we have to fight all right we
start fighting next game okay we have to just full fight
everyone Wait, are you still lagging, though?
I feel like I'm lagging, but like I'm just ignoring it
mentally.
Yeah, you choose if you believe there's no lagging.
Maybe there isn't.
There's nothing I can do about it, so I'll just ignore it.
All right, now I'm going to be...
The fact that we even rescued there was only for the fact
that there were so many teams there that they couldn't
finish you.
Thank fucking God.
See, everybody's fighting.
Nobody's playing zone.
There's a fight to our left as well.
They're freaks, man.
These guys think they're playing pubs.
We're just going to run around and get all the beacons in
the world until we have, like, purple, red, and we're just
going to fight the first team we see.
Look at that!
There's only four teams they're fighting!
What the fuck am I looking at?
Why can't we do that?
I don't know.
Why can't that be us?
Maybe stop dying?
Oh, okay.
Hey, Doki, scan the ring.
Okay, no smoke.
That's fine.
You can't blame me for that.
You can't blame me.
Why is there four teams in Prowler Nest?
Why are they there?
Like, what are they looking for?
The fucking hidden treasure from Captain Morgan?
You can't blame it on me!
You call me the scat!
Listen, I was listening.
The other game, you sit on a roof and three teams beam me up
same time.
Hey, Doki, do the people scan.
Okay, let me do the people scan as there was no smoke.
And my Bangalore was looking away from me while I get shot
at.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's my fault.
First game.
And then your Bangalore rescued.
I didn't die first.
First game, you both got.
You can't gasp your way out of this.
You can't gasp your way out.
Second game.
certain situations that you can't gaslight your way out of
and this is one of them yes i can chat who's right me or
imperial rpr of course imperial rpr is always right it's
always reps and heaven fault you don't know this guys who's
right guys imperial rpr or oh my god look how many rpr in
your chat.
Wow.
Even your viewers know you're like, they're saying veto more
than ditto.
Yeah, because ditto's on my side.
We're whole, their hosts and their devs are always together.
No.
Ditto, are you on my side?
Yes.
No.
See?
Oh.
Yeah, Ditto and ditto votes together.
Why am I too?
We want, I'm not going to IGL anymore.
Why am I getting too involved if I'm an IGL?
I'm not going to IGL anymore.
You guys ideal then.
You always get 2v1.
Imperial Hal is able to get 2v1.
No.
Imperial 1.
Imperial Hal 1v1 V2s.
There's a difference.
You're just the...
What can I say?
You're just the poor man's Imperial.
You guys are poor man's reps in the event.
Like, what the fuck is going on?
No, we're the better version of reps in for Hulse because
we're anime girls.
We're the better version because we're anime girls.
version because we're anime girls anime girls are out of
meta that's just so 2022 like we're out of that meta what's
the meta what's the current meta huh funny people on twitch
on like twitch.tv slash rprx or twitch.tv jinksy or twitch
.tv the sketch real like funny people not anime girls anime
girls are out of meta bro this man's fucking coping no no
i'm telling you this is the meta like i follow the meta okay
i play i i play bloodhound yeah you're bloodhound now you're
catalyst oh hazel smiria someone help us is there one more
is there two more games two more games right yeah two more
games two more games and we're just running people right
we're just running at people i mean i feel like at this
point like everyone's fighting anyway like we might as well
join the fucking we might as well that's going on so we can
at least get kill points and lose like why why be smart when
you can be dumb like that's my motto yeah because we're the
better dumb players like why why why put your effort in
being smart we need to be
I mean to be fair that's you yeah that's you on default
though You're like you literally like half an hour ago
admitted that you are not smart you said I'm dumb Yeah but
like but like I have smart moments Do you okay I had smart
moments in my life too like I won't yes like that was smart
that was pretty smart Yeah but that was two years ago Okay
and I do smart things every now and then
But, like, I don't need to be smart anymore.
Like, I can be dumb.
I'm in a position where I can be dumb.
So, why would I put effort in being smart?
I can just be dumb.
To win the tournament.
To win easier.
Who the fuck cares?
I'm, like, 25% Manera, 25% dumb, 50% 50% don't care.
This is the life I lead.
Holy shit.
The first place team is 79%.
points that's crazy yeah i mean the balancing is just out of
this world there's the balance is just out we just blame it
on balancing and we're good yeah that team doesn't have a
pro player the balancing is way out the balancing is crazy i
fear that team doesn't even have a pro player the balancing
is crazy in what way they probably have three controllers
controllers therefore uh 0.4 that's 40 of all their efforts
is controlled by an ai therefore mnk 40 of their point
that's bullshit there's no way all of them mnk absolutely
not possible you don't know this you're just gaslighting no
i'm speaking where's callus where's callus where's okay
there okay you don't even know where we're all we're done i
have like callus in like a two two two plus months oh my god
Ah, my cable's stuck on my chair.
What?
What happened?
I watched your stream.
She's going through a lot right now.
Almost my head.
Almost run over my head.
She's going through a lot.
And whose fault is it?
No, I mean, the first place team They have good ping.
That's the reason.
That too.
That is also a valid factor.
I literally asked you, are you okay with playing on NA ping?
And you said yes.
Our good ping player is not doing shit.
You said we're going to destroy the tournament.
I was like, are you okay with playing on NA ping?
And you're like, yes.
Okay, well, but unforeseen circumstances happen.
One, I'm lagging like a bitch.
Two, what is this balance?
Like, what the fuck?
They have three Fred players on one team.
You're telling me that's okay?
What?
For which one?
Which team?
The first team?
First place team is not three Fred players.
It's like two.
Who are they?
Do you know them?
It's Kaisa and Hachi.
You're telling me Kaisa and Hachi are dropping 79 points?
Yeah, they are.
Who's their third?
I don't know, Seroku or some shit.
I don't fucking know who that guy is.
that's literally a team of magic our team is literally three
fred players okay bro okay three fred players stop the cap
none of us have gotten fred in like four years calm down
yeah but the first place team never touched fred okay but
like touching fred means nothing in game yeah and they never
they've been masters we've all been masters is why are we
not first we might not have why are you not killing anyone
then why are you not killing everyone then i was like a
couple of people
don't probably go kill everyone uh why are you not killing
anyone why aren't you not killing anyone why aren't you not
why aren't you killing everyone i'm killing people finishing
them you're not finishing them i'm the one with the most
issues here and you give me the most i literally have people
teleporting like what are you on for me that's your you
issue you don't yeah so help me out and kill someone we do
we knock people you don't finish them for us what am i
supposed to trade my life away for a finish yeah because
then at least we get kill points Yeah, and when we die, you
get one kill point and you die and think that's how you play
tournaments?
That's better than zero kill points.
I just can't handle you.
There's no way you're serious.
You're not even serious about his tournament.
What do you mean?
I was so serious.
I'm, like, literally the only one that's taking this
seriously.
And Ditto.
Me and Ditto are literally...
Me and Ditto are both taking this so seriously.
I'm not taking I'm the one that's not taking it seriously
you told me to scan the people speaking without a smoke you
didn't even smoke for me predict four teams to be here when
the zone is here yeah but a good igl would smoke in advance
a good igl would predict that yeah okay let me go let me go
out zero zero would have told uh would tell gen the smoke
for psychs spikes or avail increase ultimate length or
increase always old always old always old every every old
ultimate length and ultimate uh what's it called duration
okay i'm ready to do go whenever uh yeah we got we're
running at people right let's fight yeah but we first want
to get purple we don't want to fight with shitty fucking
walmart armor how do we get purple okay i'm doing literally
the enemy okay we're gonna scan every single beacon until we
have purple all right i'm taking the redeploy to you we're
gonna go here next taking the cannon to you hello oh my god
i'm juicing the spiders you're doing so well these spiders
will juice the gold mags and purple stalks and shit like
what the fuck we're rich but that's crazy there's people in
in the okay there's people in the see this like we want to
go here so we can hit two more scans all right oh my god
stop teleporting we don't have ditto with us yeah we're
going to shoot them we're going to kill them it's just going
to be you and me though because it is far yeah yeah yeah
that's fine we're going to wait for area okay i have one bat
only do you guys
cheer be careful be careful dito hurry up let's go yeah
she's so far and swift okay this team scanned us from far
away i want to play from the door here to see if there's
team still here or not
are they still there i don't see anyone but they could be
riding in this
the mineswee is fine we want to hit this beacon dito and
then when the ring closes we want to hit the ring console
again okay and then that should give us purple i think
we can't fight i can't see anybody i'm scared yeah i
understand i think they i think they finally rotated into
the zone wow great job guys rotation in this enemy you lobby
well i need that i should probably why is that why is that
door juiced up why is that door juiced up i don't like that
should we scan yeah scan them dito okay good good good come
here and hit the juicer okay yeah you should smoke here yeah
where's the smoke igl i smoked it oh there's a car behind us
what the fuck oh look at these guys riding look at him
riding who what the fuck no i knew you said there's a car
there or they one team here one team here too yeah yeah i'm
coming over here i cannot my bullets are not registering
they are not registering i repeat no registration oh no oh
no oh no i'm back a little low yeah i have to i have to he's
playing he's playing juiced sentinel it's not fair what is
that shit they're running back all right let's go to the
tunnel while we can four fucking teams again.
Yay.
I won bad now.
I'm so sad.
Are we not doing the map?
CN?
No, because they're there and I don't want Dines fucking
doing it.
All right.
I mean, you can smoke me.
Yeah, and what if they just decide, oh, let's go, let's go
back for no reason at all?
They would never.
No way.
Yeah.
Listen, we need to adapt to the IQ in the lobby which is not
very high okay guys i was gonna tell us a while how many
spikes can i have up at one okay two doors is three right is
doors three doors is two doors is two they used to be three
i guess you took it away oh wait someone smoked their their
juice in it blue armor can people stop teleporting i'm
actually gonna have a moment with myself.
Are they just gonna, can you scan the building?
Are they just gonna sit there?
Like we want that bacon.
We want the bacon.
Where are you guys, where are they going?
Oh, what's cake?
Swing two.
That's the motherfuckers with the Sentinel.
Are we gonna start?
Are we gonna fight?
I want to, yeah.
All right.
They scan, the people scan.
12 seconds.
I'm fucking, I'm halting them.
Oh, they're trying to settle.
We need to get closer, that Sentinel's useless.
wait another team another team another team another team
another team turn right okay okay we can't fight this
anymore that's so annoying what the fuck are you trying to
pull up damage go here all right i'm heading over hit the
hpr um i'm gonna i i literally might have to craft a bat
here yeah i have one bat left too we're getting like thirded
so fast too yeah if oh they're fighting i hear them fighting
like behind us on the spiders maybe we can throw that okay
i'm gonna craft a bat as well yeah craft a bat he used he
used evict tower i got it okay you're fighting behind us
right no i think they're fighting on this house just here
also i have an alt excel do you want it oh yeah i want yeah
yeah i'm good
Someone fly to us.
This one fly to us.
Fucking Sentinel guys here.
Someone fly to us.
Okay.
They know we're not with us.
You're not with us.
No, no, no, no.
They come to us here.
Can you wall me?
Wall, wall, wall me.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll smoke you.
Oh, I already walled it.
I heard wall.
And then I walled.
Okay, it's been nice.
Almost killed that guy.
Almost killed Watson.
Dude, I kind of want to like kill these guys.
They're just mirroring us the entire time.
Like, fuck off.
Is that a Sentinel team?
Are they achieving?
Yeah, it's a single team.
Can you scan this building?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, they're just there.
I just got three Noregs.
Nice.
Love the game.
I don't see them.
Not a Noreg.
Nice.
Are you in there?
Yeah, they're in here.
Second floor.
Almost cracked another one.
Should I push up or no?
Five seconds to scan.
Cracked Watson?
Like, these guys are getting beamed up.
I'm...
yeah i'm pushing up i'm pushing up get climb up here yeah
i'm trying to get i took the door i took the door wait a bit
i think we actually have to go zone because it's so far in
me it's only a minute i'm smoking you and come back to me
yeah yeah i might be dead oh i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead from
this oh wait i'm alive i'm alive you're alive you're alive
you're alive you're alive i'm back down here down here down
here down here they're looking for her okay okay i'm fine
okay okay i'm gonna reinforce i'm medicating what look for
her dita they're down here okay i will scan after we have 44
seconds crack one almost crack two can you scan these guys
are suicidal let's go okay leave or oh okay come come come
come with me come with me we go we leave them and we gate
keep them there's the only thing you can do oh it got shot
you good dita yeah i'm good I have, we have a redeploy that
we can use.
I'm redeploying here to get ahead of them.
Okay.
Hey, I'm all of us.
Be careful.
Land on these spiders and gatekeep these guys.
Okay.
Oh, they're going left.
Fuck.
Fuck, pussies.
Should we kill the spiders?
Yeah, we do spiders so far, Eva.
Yeah, that's the thing we do.
Even the spiders are fucking...
wait what there's a squad uh from command center command
center okay keep watching the command center team okay like
suck a dick should we go behind us no right double checking
they could walk up behind us but i don't okay this guy's
shooting smoke he's cheating
oh nice okay i got i got a lime bag if you guys want for
some reason yeah i need oh we got zones still like we're
still chilling on them okay okay two bad still cells one bad
six cells uh one bad oh wait 13 shield cells if anyone needs
shield cells i hate this i give something to it i guess just
six okay i gave three i'm watching left side here we can
maybe trip out of here.
Oh, look at this guy.
One HP on Watson.
Oh, come back.
That's the Watson team in there.
Someone's raising there.
I kind of want to get close here and grieve this team.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm pushing up.
Let's talk him up.
Let's get the building.
I can put a wall.
I don't think we need it.
Okay.
Oh, he's on the fucking door.
But I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm going to dis-tie the door.
I'm on the roof.
I'm going to take the door.
actually.
I got a bet.
I'll take their door if you can.
I'm going to get on the window.
I took their door.
That's theirs.
They're on the stairs.
They've been gulped.
They have a Jain on the left stair.
I can get rid of the door whenever.
Wait, I did it.
Okay.
Who's shooting you?
New team or?
No, no.
The same team.
They are coming to me.
I'm looking.
I'm looking for you.
not they're not they're not they're not they're not they're
not they're not they're beaming me around the fucking whole
corner apparently they're coming they're coming oh what the
is that i might need help kill this guy kill this guy he's
alone how can how can he know oh how can he know i got it
yeah i died around the whole corner that was bullshit what
am i supposed to do there wait i think this is your corner
no no this links are scene this is links you see i see
fucking 200 ping andy of course i are on the corner wait but
links are also eu yeah it's double ping you guys could run
corners even more on his skin i was probably still on the
building but when did you both cancel each other out yeah
it's double ping i have 200 he has 200 it's like 400 minus
it's crazy it's double ping
it's double ping it's double ping it's crazy
oh they're dead yeah karma yeah yeah karma yeah oh my god he
got thirsted holy shit you gotta thirst for cold blood They
beam so hard.
By the way, the team in the first place, you said it's Hachi
and Kaisa.
You're lying out of your ass.
It's zero nothing.
No, it is.
No, it's zero nothing.
No, it's num nuts.
What are you?
No, it's zero nothing.
Oh, yeah, it is.
I...
Who are they?
I don't know who they are.
Zero nothing and JC.
I don't know who these people are.
active pro i don't know who these people are you're just
straight lying we're just lying now you didn't fact check me
i just fact checked you it took you like so long they're
literally three friends like you want some they're actually
19th place yeah i know i just saw i'm like dude kaisen had
you destroying this lobby you're just straight lying out of
your I wasn't lying, I was, I read it wrong.
Read it wrong, what did you turn the litterboard upside
down?
What happened?
Yes, I told you, I'm not that smart.
You're the one that, in fact, you're the one that didn't
fact check the dumb person.
Now, you're right, I should never trust my teammates.
You're right.
You're the IGL, you should think for yourself.
Yeah, you're right, no, this is my mission.
mistake it is my mistake to ever trust you in anything as
the igl you should know like i was wrong that you're a liar
yeah i got it i mean i admitted it right off the bat like
like i mean yeah but still it's like yeah the fact that you
might as well have you to trust me after i i said i'm a liar
is really your fault i might as well have you on mute
because like you're just
are there you can't mute me no i think i'm good you might be
even lying about that who knows
you might be lying about like i don't know are you having
fun yeah yeah it's great fun wow so much fun right dito yeah
that was the worst yeah i ever heard my life
I'm having the best time of my life friends I can trust you
I can't trust her I can't X people in the same team Fuda and
Zero Nothing play on the same ALGS team
I'll say that again Fuda and Zero Nothing the members of the
first place team are playing in the same algs team yeah but
anybody can sign up in algs anybody can sign up zero nothing
i was in algs and cc has been playing pro for five years
yeah but he's never made it what do you mean he's never made
it he's been on g2 and like many other ores what are you on
about yeah but i don't know who he is so he's never made it
oh my god you're such a narcissist it's insane
she thinks the world revolves around her thank you 25 queues
they have 25 queues yeah bro they're playing lgs against a
couple of vtubers that's what i'm saying this is not vtuber
tournament because there's not enough vtubers there's not
enough vtubers to make a vtuber tournament
this is my reality if i don't know who they are you never
made it i told them to pack their bags they're done they're
done for the day wait how did they get into a vtuber
tournament wait a minute that's actually a good question are
they in the vtuber tournament of it.
Because, like, I'd understand the other pro players because
they know VTubers.
Which VTuber do they know?
I don't think they have a VTuber on their team.
Wait, what?
Why are they here?
Wait, why are they here?
I would assume they would have at least one VTuber.
They're literally playing ALGS and we're over here in
Kindergarten wait people are actually saying they don't have
one wait what the fuck they don't even they don't even have
a vtuber on their team no they don't they actually don't is
this isn't this a vtuber to the main no yeah by name
by name it's supposed to be a vtuber tournament no we over
here plugging in league and they're playing lgs this is not
fair their 3d model is just that insane
guys guys you don't understand guys to be fair there's not
enough na apex vtubers or eu to be fair type one in shots to
kick a nominates at the tournament everyone's typing one all
right pack To be fair, they're all swarming from EU.
And you know how bad EU prize.
You don't make money in EU.
They need this.
I mean, am I...
Is that bad?
EU's pretty bad when it comes to prize pools.
You know that.
How many points do they get right now?
They got 25 kills, man.
Yeah.
I think they've had multiple 20 kill games in this lobby I
mean they're just running I mean they're running at people
who don't even play this game something like not don't play
but like obviously not that level so it's like very easy for
them but I'm saying it's so fucking unbalanced like no one
can say anything we have ALGS team in first place and then
everyone else like they have like a hundred points already
like what are we playing what do I sign up for fucking for a
second place.
Like, I think even if we killed everyone in the lobby and
won the game and respawn farm, then we can't catch up to
them.
we'd need to go on like a, like a, we'd need to respawn farm
every single team once in this lobby and we still wouldn't
catch up to them.
Wait, even we respawn farm, what if we all work together
with the other teams and just respawn farm them?
Justin Pete yeah we should just kick them kick them out to
tournament yeah but they're still gonna be first place no
matter what delete the wads delete their points move along
i'd deal with them quick then second place is first place
now guys yeah first place no bread second place all bread
and also wherever we land should be like a extra prize pool
guys just start the game guys i don't care i
guys if they're trying to figure out what to do with team
the first place team i don't care just gg go next i just
started so much drama bro i don't care bro it's literally
first place was literally 125 dollars i don't care i just
started so much drama i'm just gonna sit here and laugh like
in the beginning of the stream i already made more than the
tournament just go i just stirred this pot i just stirred
this pot and i'm i'm just gonna relax and watch it unfold
before my eyes this is the best entertainment i feel what
did you do this is so good you're gonna be late to your
fucking other scene we didn't even get ahead of schedule
this is karma this is karma for gaslighting this is karma
for your gaslighting this is karma for your gaslighting i
was gonna leave exactly at three it doesn't matter i would
leave in the middle of the game if i have to this is karma
why manhara activated i start i'm studying i'm gonna start
this drama bro next is the lingser lingser dude kick lingser
next he's a current pro where's your vtuber start taking the
lobby kick all the 3d models out 3d models i'm starting now
this is minera mode oh you don't have a vtuber oh oh my god
i'll be out no vtuber mobile you're out no no vtuber model
no play
can't sit i gotta go he called me k and holy shit
why aren't we i wait why aren't we starting i'm so confused
why why aren't we i actually think i actually i might have
started some shit though actually did you maybe like people
are yelling bro what if people are rating the poor organizer
stream wait wait are they the if you're if you're going on
the organized stream and talking shit talking shit like
actually i actually do not do that don't be weird it's all
memes we're we'll only talk behind the scene yeah don't talk
to their face bro yeah yeah do it bob yeah rpr is teaching
us a lesson right now talk shit behind their backs is that
right rpr is that right that's what you said, not me I
literally reiterated what you just said I just rephrase it I
said don't go in their chat and talk shit I said don't go in
their chat and talk shit like in their face Yeah but you
were talking shit behind their backs this entire time That
it's called a joke Sure Yeah sure a joke You but you lost
your humor Like you don't know Don't know jokes anymore
happened but you didn't say on sarcasm well do i have to
stay say slash s at the end of every sentence like what is
this twitter yes i'm a little special i can't read i can't
read people trust me we know you're special i'm a little bit
a little bit i think i think a little bit more a little bit
there a little bit more than that what does that mean what
does that mean no nothing let's get let's go land on our
landing spot yeah no youtube master okay
so i say we just fucking i don't fucking let's kill everyone
and if you told them we killed them they died they died but
we didn't kill everybody we kept running away we run into
the first place team what do you want from me he's got three
breads and two poor pro players what do i do uh i did a
thousand damage we still didn't kill anyone one more can i
do 2000 damage if i had controller at the 1v3 then plug it
in you literally have your roller next to me i can't do that
i can't play a tournament controllers that's so beneath me
it's insane my like i would i would lose all my achievements
I've ever made in like five seconds for plugin controller
during tournament people love roller players look at Jen
Burton someone in my chat said is TSM playing we're
literally TSM yeah we're literally TSM TSM is in this
tournament guys guys we're in a tournament with TSM chat we
are TSM what do you mean with TSM we are TSM yeah we got
signed you literally got signed gotta say this version TSM
kind of sucks ass yeah but you're the IGL so it is your
follow that's not how things work in life you can just blame
everything on the game leader yes you can that's the whole
point you have to reflect on your own actions sometimes no
but my game leader doesn't teach me well we'll teach you
what you're unteachable I'm not we use yeah Tekken
tournament.
And I was taught to be better.
He's not Apex Legends.
Nope, but it's competitive.
Sure.
Are you trying to say fighting games are not competitive?
No, I think Street Fighter's competitive, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
What about Tekken?
Yeah, yeah.
You don't think Tekken's competitive.
Yeah, yeah, no, no.
That's fucked up.
Guys, he doesn't think Tekken's competitive.
I think whatever game you play is just not competitive.
So I play Apex.
Exactly.
So Apex is not competitive.
So your achievements don't count because Apex isn't
competitive.
No, when I played was competitive.
Now it's just us.
You think this game is competitive?
Like this game is the most RNG bullshit on the planet.
Like it's probably the least competitive.
Like it's a VR.
When you used to play it, it was even more RNG than before.
No, no, no.
It was less RNG because there was no aim assist involved.
It actually took skill to shoot people.
Okay, we have to go again.
Okay.
Oh, my God, we got zone.
I'm going to cry.
Yeah.
I don't want zone.
I thought we were going to run at people.
What happened?
We can't run at people if you have zone.
Like, why do we keep giving a zone?
No!
What is wrong with them?
I don't want to keep making me.
in zone it's scary i need any game that allows an ai
computer to aim for you is not a competitive game maybe in a
mixed in a mixed input environment better than a controller
player just use your movement i mean if i install in but i
got that why do you say ditto i'm gonna go gap though okay
i need to open this red bin there's people over there on the
left already we just people are shooting already wait people
are shooting people are literally shooting each other and
going to zone now yes let's go let's go up top i mean oh my
god this is so sad we don't get loot we don't get evos they
just cucked us why do we get zone because they hate zone
they hate us too stupid
i can't do anything with this like three in times and out of
six games i think i think kura is literally just grieving us
on purpose like displacing these zones around our fucking
forehead they're fighting kind of which way just poking 100
not gonna fight they were fighting earlier I saw them.
It's this team and this team.
They're smoking and, like, poking.
Oh, there's needs.
Granata.
Granata number one, two.
I'm going to check behind us.
It's fucking Catalyst.
They're never going to fucking fight.
This guy just made a double door out of...
Oh, is that one knock?
No, they killed a fire.
I'm going to get this door.
And then this door.
and then i'm gonna put i'm gonna put spikes right here what
am i like okay why am i again i'm always lying where are
they should put all the spikes below there they got
cryptolted wow that's just craze oh wait she's cray i'm
gonna put all the spikes below us now i'm above us at this
like you get zoned and then what you sit here no bats none i
have i have i have six bats bats i can give six bats i got
one number four oh here you're bad thank you oh look reapply
reapply they're gonna take it yeah they made it come on come
on there come then you're going to our left here okay
they're going to the nut they landed on the nut yeah they're
gonna nut huh they're gonna nut they're going to nut 20
flesh where nut oh yeah they're nutting wait num nuts died
they find they can bleed oh who would have thought how the
fuck did you how did they die in this lobby
we need a water review how do you die to fucking vtubers
fucking vtubers how do you die it's so embarrassing that is
so embarrassing like god you'll just even die to fucking I
know you went to pro league how do you die that's like sweet
dying to a vtuber I know that's so embarrassing that's so
embarrassing I know right I never die to a vtuber okay
active pro dying to vtubers is crazy it's like dying to an
overwatch player igls in the world dying to a vtuber is
actually like just you died to an overwatch player too you
died to a vtuber and an overwatch player i didn't yes you
did you died to sure for yeah but i died to an overwatch
player i didn't die yeah so you died to both apex and you
died to a vtuber and an overwatch player no no no sure for
now i turned overwatch pro oh yeah he has a v2 model that he
doesn't use there he did he uses every wednesday what the is
he changed i remember when he was like i don't i don't want
to use it i don't want to yeah so you did die to a vtuber oh
he's low he's right back then he wasn't a vtuber so didn't
account which one did oh who's low oh no he's he's getting
inside the building.
Look at these guys.
What are you guys walking in the open for, huh?
Or just teleporting in the open more like it.
Can I just grieve?
Like, I really want to just grieve like...
Grieve who?
These guys.
Make sure there's nobody behind us.
Yeah, you guys just make sure that I'm going to grieve.
Alright, I'm going to find here.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Yeah, they're finding here.
Like, this is so third party.
okay okay i'm ready we're going i'm heading over and i'm
cooking i'm looking and i'm cooking actually you can yeah
we'll see up here one hp and one wait he's so low they're
all low no they had to we keep these guys out i'm gonna look
behind us i'm gonna look behind us you guys how did that not
break the door i want to make sure nobody comes behind us
because we've had that happen too many times on me okay i'm
looking back to help i can't i don't understand his movement
purple coming up coming up the ramp coming up the ramp yeah
they're coming up here yeah yeah i saw them rocking up this
is my old weather i want to fight this team i want them dead
okay are they up the ramp i don't see them I don't know if
they're below or they went below, yeah.
Come on, pick it.
Wait, there's a guy still there.
Is this guy still in the building?
Wait, what?
Yeah, yeah, I saw a guy.
There's a guy literally right inside.
There's three people below.
I guess that's a rat.
It has to be a rat, right?
He's like, literally, he's inside.
Here!
Purple?
He's still in zone.
There's two guys, I think.
What is that bag?
over there they came up they came up yeah but we have to
watch this yeah i was seeing it's terrible he's behind
they're behind they're way behind i'm here in zone they're
in zone i'm looking at them there's no way they got meds for
that you guys don't got the facilities for that big man
right here i'm paying they're on their bridge oh they went
so far we we kill we kill we kill they're fighting there
they're fighting there i'm gonna i'm gonna look for these
guys in zone first i'm looking at them in zone they're still
in zone can you still see them yeah they're right here we're
at ping there's no way they are meds for this i hit them
once so they'll die if they die they'll wait someone died to
ring is that them oh no no i see him he's not playing on i
hit him 40 purple he's running right side okay what the is
he doing oh no he's right below me he's fighting him i can
see i can't see he's still reporting for me jesus christ
come help me come on maybe let's kill this guy oh yeah i'll
come over he's gonna kill me like he must have meds team
over here what i'm looking at i knock one i knock one okay
um okay i'm gonna push where were you were you okay wait i
might be dead to zone i live i got the queue nice nice nice
let's go for Fuck him up.
I'm looking behind.
I want to make sure that nobody walks up to us.
No mercy this game.
No mercy.
Over there.
One team.
New team.
Come in, Dito.
Oh, look.
They're flying.
I'm looking.
Are you coming?
Are you going back to the...
I'm going to go back to the key.
I'll let you...
There's a lot.
Lotty here.
Yeah, there's two teams.
Red armor on my left.
Dito, watch for me.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's a whole team game.
I don't have heavy ammo.
I need more ammo either.
I'm gonna change.
There's a lot of light ammo here.
There's three men team is here, right?
Oh, they're fighting each other.
They got two knocks.
I saw two knocks.
I knocked one.
Oh, there.
Tank, I'm past playing it.
Flash, flash, flash it on Lifeline.
No, no, focus this team.
This team is like two down, I think.
I think they're full dead, aren't they?
No, no, no, they're not.
They're not.
Because I knocked on it and didn't get the kill.
He's right below me here.
Okay.
Last guy.
Yeah, scan.
Yes, scan.
Okay, yeah, I'm gonna scan, scan.
I'm gonna cover you from this team, but I need energy ammo.
It's just this guy down here.
Do you need help?
No, this guy's just running.
I want to find... Is there energy ammo?
Oh, wait.
There might be people below us.
I don't want to risk it.
This botan is here solo.
His teammates are still crawling.
There's, I hear there's a point.
Oh there, oh there.
We don't want one team.
Careful, careful.
I don't have energy ammo anymore, so I need a chill.
I want one team.
I can give it to you, Tom.
Okay, thank you.
I still didn't get my kill.
Like, he's still just crawling.
Yeah, I didn't get anything as well.
This guy's going for the package.
He's got red armor.
I'm so laggy that's insane like how am I supposed to hit
that teleporting looking ass
what oh there he is that's like where am I getting shot from
I'm out of heavy ammo completely I got the kill on I have
heavy I have heavy I can give you yeah I might get walked up
on uh I hear I hear this guys on the zip planes yeah I have
spikes though so yeah Should we find all suspects below us?
Wait, hold up.
I'm gonna throw my havoc here with like 30 ball- no havoc,
sorry.
Yeah, someone- there's someone down here.
Yeah, that's part of the scene.
It's part of the scene.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna play Sentinel to poke.
Somebody's flying here, flying here!
Yeah, they're flying below.
They're- they're falling right here.
I might fight?
Oh, they're all the way down here.
There's more- Oh, I'm gonna take that.
60 on this, uh, Newcastle?
I'm gonna look- I'm gonna look here.
look here because i don't have a spice here for us there's
people smoking i'm gonna scan i'm gonna
scan hallelujah i made one let's see if i can grab some of
those right there cool okay they're fighting like crazy oh i
missed that they're fighting here was there a six times cop
anywhere uh i don't think so i i don't know honestly i
didn't check I remember seeing one, but maybe I'm just...
There's a team here.
Right below us.
There's a team here that's crafting.
What is...
Oh my god, a lot.
A lot of people, but I don't have ammo.
Oh my god, this guy's one shot.
This guy has red armor.
Oh, I have two mags left.
I'm gonna stop.
I can't poke.
I can't poke anymore.
These guys won.
nice we got better ring team here one ping you're fighting
there i can't do anything this team is smoking us okay okay
and he's shooting me just what are you cheating bastard this
team has to come to us this team has to come to us just
watch on watch only that team that's shooting only only that
team you guys watch that i'll watch everything else yeah i'm
watching here i'm watching here both both of you watch here
there's a team uh there's two teams there's two teams one to
Ditto.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, this team is moving on the right.
Are they both moving to the right?
They're both moving to the right.
Yeah.
I hate lag.
Okay, that should have hit.
I'm going to make sure.
I don't want to waste ammo, so I'm just...
But they're crafting here.
They dropped to the left.
Okay, so they're not coming for us.
No.
This buffering is 70.
Wow, I'm getting maggot drill.
Wow, this game went on longer now that there's, like, you
know, no one, none of the pro team is alive.
Isn't that crazy?
It's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
What a thought.
That the pro team isn't killing everybody.
But that's how it works.
I got a scan right below me.
Let's see.
Where are the other doors?
draining everyone's fucking meds are you open nice nice i
missed that is an embarrassment for my family i i can't
shoot anymore i don't have ammo that's fine you know to
shoot save it for the last stream there's so many people
dying that want to shoot people up here do you have a nade
there's a guy behind this box alone i think yeah i have a
nade i have a nade purple which one I need him right here.
You see this box right here?
This blue box?
Yeah.
Oh, I see him.
Cracked him.
Nice.
He has teammates somewhere.
We got it.
Nice.
Feel him to my right.
We literally have prio zone.
Oh, my God.
I'm so scared of falling down.
So don't fall.
wouldn't it be funny
they're running out here yeah
awesome as fuck yeah if you just stop teleporting for a
second so I can hit you okay but what if like mobbing rising
here they're not rising there's just calling in mobs 88 on
this guy 88 again he's rising he's rising oh my god that was
so close how do you get it off that was so close
that's crazy oh god i want to shoot so bad running out here
one 120 headshot right below me 120 headshot bangalore okay
i have two nades i'm just gonna wait he's literally one that
bang oh my god how are you not blind i can't hit we're like
last to jump down i think from here nice where 95 headshot
there one team here they have a zip on us what What the fuck
are you doing?
What the fuck are they doing?
Are you guys okay?
Like what?
Just the surprises.
They just died, right?
Yeah, you died for that.
I was like, what?
I'm gonna bang gold.
I'm gonna place some spikes down there.
That's yours, right?
Yeah, here, here.
You stay here.
I will scan.
okay they're all right below us we can like that is
definitely not yours this time why are you shooting on me
bro ow like what the fuck get on top get on top dito we're
gonna like we're gonna jump down in wall okay they're gonna
fight they got knocks they got knocks coming me coming me i
need a wall walls up on me on Watson, Watson on me.
Nice.
I'm there, I'm there.
Come play my nook.
Nice, play my nook.
No, I got hit.
It's up to you, Ditto.
Behind you, behind you.
Ah!
It's f- I killed them.
Let's hear them.
Nice try, nice try.
Nice try.
I forgot to nade.
I had two nades too, I should have just threw my nades down
there.
Why did they just zip on us?
That was crazy.
That zip was actually crazy.
I was so confused.
I was like, what?
did that actually happen
that was like i was like no they're not going to take it
yeah i look i stared at him for two seconds because i
thought he was going to get off the zip but then he kept
going so i shot him i was like wait what i mean nine kills
last game you showed some dominance i'm just saying bro the
boys got to fix 16 what do you there's a team below us they
got 16 okay that's that's links there isn't it yeah those
players don't count all the elders players should lose all
their points and should all go to us instead so true okay
ggs guys i don't even know what placement what placement did
we get what placement did we get let me shake let me shake
is it updated it's not it's not updated not yet yeah no no
it did game six yeah hey we got third hey how the hell do we
get to do an interview you know i'll take it we got third
from a second place that's actually crazy that we got there
no do we have to do an interview do we have to i thought the
interview is only i know made you for nominate rpr no no no
no i have to go in four minutes yeah yeah well you know you
invited me to this tournament you're the team leader you
should just totally like you said yes you agreed no no no no
no you should do the interview why do do do we need to yeah
um do an interview yes
good at interview but if i do interview i'm gonna go see
some super like i'm getting an old man let up here do it let
up here do it oh my god dude there's no way they're gonna
interview the third place to him like there's no need to
like yes i think he they will interview only for space yeah
that's true right they're not gonna yeah why would anyone
talk to us yeah they already talked to like people already
like yeah like we're not like dude talk to the lgs but
players abusing this tournament yeah exactly talk to the num
nuts guys yeah took them took them do to them they deserve
it fucking shame them live on stream whoa shame them whoa i
didn't say that they deserve it all right are we actually do
we actually have to do the interview
didn't even read the rules of the okay to be fair i have
read the rules i don't even know all right let's see where's
the rules questions uh where's the rules okay we're all just
champion no i'm not german ass i'm not no i'm not no
champion i'm third place yeah i'm just third place place oh
my god iOS pace have have a lot of point like twice Oh,
there's no interviews.
There's no interviews.
Let's go.
All right, GGs, everybody.
GGs, we did it.
Third place.
Wow, GGs are so fun.
We're so good at this game.
GGs, guys, we got third place.
Hey, wasn't even trying.
Wasn't even trying.
Got third place.
Yeah, wasn't even trying.
Team Slightly Manhara.
We're going crazy.
Teams, not slightly anymore here, Manhara.
Anyway, TSM is going to suspend this.
and i uh deaths and i are gonna look for a new igl uh we
figured if you guys wanna if you guys wanna um make some
like fun art of like us like disbanding like i'm gonna go to
dark zero from now on so this is gonna be our last
tournament yeah like this is um hero rpr's last tournament
as tsm we are disbanding now because uh ditto and i got
better so we're not minhara anymore so he has to go to guys
want to memorize this moment for the end of eternity you
guys can make some fun out if you want uh but just know that
i'm believing because i just need a better environment than
this environment this one is too toxic for me and i just
don't think we can win like this so i'm i just gotta do
what's better for my career and i think moving to dark zero
is actually gonna give me a chance to win from now onwards
and like we think as tsm the last two members in tsm we
believe that like imperial rpr was uh was was too much of an
anchor uh so we will be trailing new igl starting next week
yeah and also as an igl i just can't believe that i'm igl
and i'm also outputting more damage than ver holst and reps
together like they all put 7 000 damage together and i 8 000
damage like this is insane like this is why i need better
teams that's why i need gen tired of igl i just want to frag
out because i really have the talent for it and i just want
to go to like an igl just tell me what to do and i got
teammates that do a ton of damage because my team just
doesn't do you are i do you do a lot of damage because you
are igl because you know when to shoot exactly we don't know
and if if we didn't um listen to your order and if if we
shoot you are gonna mad at us yeah yeah you guys are not
shooting enough anyway because how do you guys never have
how do you never have ammo but do no damage you don't tell
you ask you ask you ask you're taking your ammo yeah you're
taking your ammo you guys never have ammo you're always
yelling for light ammo so i don't have light ammo anymore
now listen this is the guys you guys can see what of TSM is
right here right now it's a toxic environment and I think
this is just a better environment for me where I can really
shine as a player
GG's guys we got third place GG's guys I gotta go plan for
wrestle tuber now I'll see you guys later GG's yeah peace
out bye bye bye guys I gotta go fucking zoom for wrestle
tuber now So, if you stay up, oh my gosh, I can't even use
my head right now.
What was my outro?
Guys, what was my outro?
I actually forgot my outro.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, there's WrestleTuber later on.
I'll see you guys soon, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.